bonjour à tous hier les sénateurs ont
débattu dans l'hémicycle des conclusions
de la commission d'enquête sur le rôle
des banques dans l'évasion fiscale cette
commission d'enquête est née dans le
sillage de l'affaire Cusac et elle a
émis 34 propositions afin de mettre plus
de transparence dans le système bancaire
parmi ces propositions il y a notamment
l'idée de faire sauter le verrou de
Bercy il faut dire qu'aujourd'hui en
matière de fraude fiscale la justice ne
peut pas agir seule elle doit avoir
l'aval du ministère de l'Économie autre
proposition mieux protéger les lanceurs
d'alerte également encadrer les
intermédiaires avocats comptables qui
ont un rôle essentiel dans le montage
financier tout de suite donc retour à
cette séance qui a eu lieu hier matin au
Sénat l'ordre du jour
appelle le débat sur les conclusions de
la commission d'enquête sur le rôle des
banques et acteurs financiers dans
l'évasion des ressources financières en
ses conséquences fiscales et sur les
équilibres économiques ainsi que sur
l'efficacité du dispositif législatif
juridique et
administratif destiné à la combattre
c'est à la demande de la commission
d'enquête la parole est à Monsieur
François Pillet président de la
commission d'enquête
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je souhaite
avant tout remercier la Conférence des
Présidents d'avoir inscrit à l'ordre du
jour ce débat sur les conclusions de la
commission d'enquête sur le rôle des
acteurs financiers dans l'évasion des
capitaux et les dispositifs destinés à
la combattre que j'ai eu l'honneur de
présider durant la trop brève période
concédée aux commissions d'enquête par
notre organisation institutionnelle je
rappelle que cette commission est née
d'une initiative de nos collègues du
groupe CRC exercé dans le cadre de la
révision constitutionnelle de 2008
adoptée par la présente la précédente
majorité à l'initiative on le sait du
président de la République nous mesurons
depuis à chaque année parlementaire les
progrès de gouvernance apporté par cet
aspect de la réforme de
2008 tout n'est peut-être pas par fait
peut-être devrions-nous réfléchir à
élargir les limites temporelles des
commissions d'enquête en particulier
lorsqu'ell chevauche des périodes de
l'année peu propices à des
investigations par ailleurs les
contraintes de temps sont proportionnell
à l'ampleur de leur objet et je dois
confesser que sous cet aspect la nôtre
aurait sans doute mérité des délais plus
en rapport avec son propos dans ces
conditions je voudrais d'abord souligner
la qualité de la contribution de notre
rapporteur éc beet qui a été l'un des
puissants motifs de l'adoption à
l'unanimité du rapport de la commission
d'enquête confronté un sujet
particulièrement difficile par son
ampleur et par les asects techniques
pluridisciplinaires qui sont les siens
disposant finalement de moyens très
comptés il a toujours évité de céder à
ce à quoi parfois on ne résiste pas en
ce cas à savoir la caricature à des fins
plus ou moins
populistes mais notre unanimité que le
rapport d'une précédente commission
d'enquête sur l'évasion fiscale
internationale avait également recueilli
sous la houlette de Philippe dominti et
déjà d'éc boet me semble aussi traduire
une sensibilité partagée qui voit comme
première condition de la justice fiscale
que les lois s'appliquent et qu'ell
s'appliquent à tous vous conséderez
certainement monsieur le ministre que le
Sénat ne vous mesure pas les moyens de
lutter contre la fraudte fiscale je
pense que vous admettrez pouvoir trouver
dans Cénat une assemblée certes
exigeante sur l'efficacité réelle de vos
projets et sur certains principes
impliquant les libertés publiques mais
qui enrichit par des propositions très
nourres l'action publique dans le champ
de la lutte antifraude au demeurant dans
la période particulièrement troupble que
nous avons traversé je veux me souvenir
que les travaux du Sénat sur les
questions qui nous réunissent
aujourd'hui loin d'avoir été négligés
ont plutôt vous le savez été comptés au
crédit de nos institutions
le contrôle par les institutions
parlementaires des pouvoirs qu'il soit
celui que vous représentez monsieur le
ministre ou qu'il relève d'autres
pouvoirs plus économique est un bien
irremplaçable auquel des les membres de
la commission d'enquête ont j'en suis
sûr eu le sentiment de contribuer pour
autant la multiplication des commissions
d'enquête et d'autres missions
d'information sur la fraude fiscale et
les moyens mis en œuvre pour la contenir
est-elle complètement satisfaisante il
faudra prendre le temps d'une réflexion
parlementaire sur nos modes
d'organisation pour répondre à ce volet
de la question des propositions ont été
formulées qui visent à rendre plus
permanent et plus collégial le contrôle
en ce domaine nous verrons bien comment
ne pas rappeler ici l'atmosphère
particulière dans laquelle la Commission
d'enquête s'est déroulée elle est été
marqué par des affaires successives dont
certaines ont été judiciarisées au cours
de ces travaux mais aussi par des
initiatives tousasimutes au niveau
international les réunions du G8 et du
G20 au niveau national une série de
projets de loi avec la loi bancaire qui
comprend plusieurs dispositifs
intéressants l'évasion des capitaux la
loi de transparence de la vie politique
qui en particulier aborde la question
des conflits d'intérêts et bien entendu
la loi sur la fraude fiscale et la
grande délinquence financière
internationale ces initiative prolonge
le mouvement déclenché en d'autres temps
au cœur de la crise financière pendant
laquelle la France avait porté très haut
les exigences de restauration de l'ordre
public financier international et
s'inscrivent dans le sillage d'une
mobilisation qui est à l'instigation
ducédent président de la République a vu
notre pays se donner de nouvelles armes
de lutte contre la fraude fiscale et
entraîner nos partenaires dans un effort
inédit pour combattre l'évasion fiscale
internationale nous devons donc nous
féliciter d'une forme de continuité à
laquelle les observations de notre
commission d'enquête dans le champ qui
était le sien invite à donner de plus
amples
prolongements mieux connaître pour mieux
combattre tel le titre de notre rapport
ce sont aussi les principaux axes des
dispositions législatives que nous avons
adopté au cours de ces derniers mois les
leçons de la crise financière sur le
potentiel d'opacité de la finance et de
ses réseaux sur les défis que représente
la connaissance fine d'organismes
gigantesques trop gros pour faire
faillite mais aussi trop gros pour être
maîtrisé sur le sentiment que les
superviseurs et les contrôleurs éprouvve
d'immenses difficultés à réunir les
informations nécessaires à leur mission
et à à leur réserver toujours le
traitement qu'il faudrait sont autant de
constat à la base de nos réflexions et
propositions nos propositions visent à
réduire l'asymétrie d'information entre
les acteurs financiers et les organismes
publics plus globalement elles tentent à
combler les handicaps que connaissent
les des administrations soumises à des
limites qu'elles doivent pouvoir
surmonter par rapport à des réseaux
internationaux pour le moins agile dans
ce programme la confiance dans l'action
publique doit gagner du terrain ce qui
est aussi un gage d'efficacité c'est à
partir de ce dernier point que je
voudrais aborder quelques sujets
d'inquiétude en premier lieu si j'ai
tout à l'heure évoqué la continuité des
majorités dans l'action contre la fraude
fiscale
elle n'est pas entière je dirait même
qu'une forme de rupture s'est produite
par rapport au contexte qui existait
avant 2012 dans le même temps où notre
pays soutient la convergence
internationale dans la lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale s'accentue la
singularité du d'une France saisie c'est
le mot d'un ministre des Finances d'un
ralbol fiscal dont l'une des issues
redoutables peut-être la fuite des
activités et donc des capitaux craignons
donc que ce que nous pourrions gagner
contre l'évasion fiscale ne soit perdu
dans la fuite des capitau et uvrons à
apparier notre politique fiscale au
progrès aussi nécessaire que
malheureusement hasardeux de
l'harmonisation fiscale notamment dans
une Europe de plus en plus éat sous cet
angle soyons aussi tout à fait convaincu
que la lutte contre l'évasion des
capitaux doit être prise en charge par
l'Europe qui ne peut laisser le champ
aux États-Unis dans ce domaine si
l'Europe n'assume pas ses
responsabilité la formidable concurrence
que suscite l'attraction des capitaux
risque de se dénouer à ses dépend donc
au autre parmi les événements intervenus
au cours de notre commission d'enquête
figure la circulaire d Caseneuve vous
nous en donnerez certainement quelques
éléments de bilan monsieur le ministre
dans la droite ligne de ce que je viens
d'évoquer et tout en étant conscient des
difficultés soulevées nous avons suggéré
que les modalités de régularisation
fiscale puissent être réétudier si elle
s'accompagnait d'une condition de
rapatriement des fonds dissimulés à
l'étranger je voudrais en second lieu
insister sur les défis que la loi
rencontre dans le domaine qui nous
occupe les différents textes que nous
avons examiné en 2013 ont été associés à
un événement au terme duquel certains
ministres ont changé de fonction
ministérielle ces lois prises dans
l'urgence de la rédaction sont bien
souvent dangereuses la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel intervenu hier
le confirme d'une certaine façon en tout
cas elle témoigne rarement d'une vision
assez complète pour embrasser l'ensemble
des éléments d'une politique publique
quand en plus la loi trouve
naturellement des difficultés à
appréhender un phénomène qui ne cesse de
lui échapper comme c'est le cas avec les
questions que pose l'évasion des
capitaux il faudrait prendre le temps de
s'interroger très soigneusement avant de
légiférer nous devons être conscient que
subsiste une certaine indétermination
sur ce qui relève d'une gestion normale
de l'impôt par les contribuables et de
ce qui se constitue une forme
d'autoexemption faisant violence à nos
lois fiscales la tentation dans ce
domaine de légiférer ponctuellement en
adoptant des dispositifs ad hoc j'ai le
sentiment quen C temp de débat sur la
réforme fiscale nous devrions commencer
par nous interroger sur le sens même de
nos grands impôts et l'adéquation entre
leur logique et les textes en vigueur il
nous faut également tirer les leçons de
l'expérience de certains dispositifs
antifraude adoptés ces dernières années
tiratisent trop large je pense à la
limitation des déductions d'intérêt qui
se sont à peu peu à peu vidé de leur
repter sous l'effet des nécessités je
pense en particulier et la récente
décision du Conseil constitutionnel ne
peut que renforcer mes propos je pense
en particulier à l'ensemble des
dispositifs pris pour pénaliser les
paradis fiscaux et les structure opaque
auxquel chacun souscrit mais qui pour
être utile doivent pouvoir être
réellement mis en œuvre enfin je
m'interroge sur l'adoption de
dispositions floues qui peuvent réduire
la sécurité juridique des agents économ
mais aussi de l'administration comme on
peut en rencontrer quand on souhaite
réformer l'abut de droit tant une
clarification de notre doctrine fiscale
qu'une amélioration de notre gestion
publique des impôts sont pour l'avenir
des étapes par lesquelles il faudra
prioritairement passer en 3ème lieu il
me faut évoquer d'un mot les attentes
déçues de ceux qui comptaient sur
l'engagement allégué de votre majorité
auprès du monde judiciaire pour faire
sauter ce qu'on appelle le verrou merci
ce sujet est revenu à plusieurs reprises
lors de nos auditions et je dirais que
la commission d'enquête était sans doute
majoritaire à estimer que des avancées
décisives devaient intervenir sur ce
point dans la mesure où des votes
étaient intervenus nous en avons tenu
compte aussi nous sommesnous contentés
d'émettre le souhait que cette
importante question puisse faire l'objet
comme dirait come on dirait dans les
parquets d'un plus ample
informé le débat sur ce point ne p que
revenir sur le devant de la scène à
mesure que la consolidation de normes
internationales progressera la
judiciarisation de l'action des services
de contrôle fiscal a certainement ses
limites juridiques au regard de la
cohérence de l'ensemble de l'action
publique rappelez-vous tous les débats
que nous avons eu lorsque nous avons
discuté sur la loi sur la faute fiscale
la dernière loi cependant nous sommes
d'ors et déjà beaucoup plus exigeant sur
d'autres points beaucoup plus exigeant
comme la nécessité de donner au service
judiciaire les moyens de leur action et
j'insiste sur une application rigoureuse
de l'article 40 du code de procédure
pénale il est toujours aventureux que
les pouvoirs constitués ne s'attachent
pas à faire respecter les lois qu'ils
adoptent mieux connaître pour mieux
combattre la soustraction des capitaux
aux nécessités reconnues de l'intérêt
public c'est un programme dont nous
aurons à connaître dans les prochaines
années au vu des calendriers d'action
convenu entre les États et des progrès
considérables à accomplir encore pour
assurer la conformité de la finance à
ses nécessités je forme le vœux qu'à
l'avenir comme dans le passé de plus
proche le Sénat puisse ne pas se
décourager de les entreprendre autant
qu'il faudra et qu'il puisse se réunir
autour d'objectifs qui nous
transcendent la parole est à monsieur
Éric Boquet rapporteur de la commission
d'enquête
ça va bien merci bien monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je souhaite en premier lieu
remercier à mon tour la Conférence des
Présidents d'avoir inscrit ce débat à
notre ordre du jour même si plusieurs
des recommandations adoptées par la
Commission ont commencé à trouver un
début de satisfaction au cours des
débats qui nous ont retenus à l'occasion
de différents projets de loi examinés au
cours de la PR PRD session
parlementaires il est utile de faire le
point et de préparer l'avenir les
missions des commissions d'enquête ne
sont pas facilitées par les moyens dont
elle dispose en droit et en fait elle
rencontre parfois l'hostilité de ceux
qu'elle dérange la commission sur le
rôle des acteurs financier dans
l'évasion des capitaux n'a pas été
épargné les fausses indignations
particulièrement scandaleuses quand
elles proviennent de fraudeur patentés
n'ont pas manqué au cours de nos travaux
nous avons pu rencontrer plusieurs
témoins menacés parfois de mort
fallait-il que le sujet soit brûlant
dans ce contexte je voudrais remercier
les membres de la commission d'enquête
d'avoir adopté les conclusions qui leur
avaient été soumises adopté donc à
l'unanimité ce résultat doit beaucoup à
la présidence de notre commission
d'enquête par François Pilet notre
collègue aussi résolu que favorable à la
réunion d'un consensus qui est désormais
bien installé au Sénat sur des sujets
qui en effet nous rassemblent de toute
évidence une commission d'enquête
parlementaire n'a pas les mêmes
objectifs que ceux assignés aux organes
de contrôle qu'il soit administratif ou
judiciaire cependant elles doivent
s'efforcer d'être les supports d'un
contrôle parlementaire auquel il
faudrait donner toute sa place dans une
démocratie où le contrôle politique doit
être fort la réponse judiciaire ne
saurait être seule à faire écho à une
démocratie d'opinion exaspéré par les
excès ou les carences des uns ou des
autres sur des sujets comme celui qui
nous rassemblent un contrôle
parlementaire permanent et collégial
devra un jour
s'imposer il est moins concurrent que
complémentaire par rapport à l'autorité
Judici et il peut même arriver qu'il
favorise l'exercice par cette dernière
de ses missions comme nous en avons reçu
plusieurs fois le témoignage
permettez-moi de rendre hommage aux
hommes et aux femmes qui s'attaquent au
crimes financiers qu'ils appartiennent à
des services ou que simples personnes
privées dans la solitude de leur
conscience ils osent dans l'exercice de
leur profession ou d'autres manières
s'opposer aux forces d'un système
évidemment bien bien plus puissant quee
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
intervenu hier ne leur rend pas cet
hommage sans doute nous direz vous
quelle suite le Gouvernement entend-il
réservé à une décision qui par divers
aspects aboutit à désamorcer les moyens
d'assurer l'égalité devant les charges
publiques dans un monde où de plus en
plus de flux de plus en plus pardon les
flux de capitaux sont affranchis de
toutes limite la financiarisation de
l'économie est un phénomène tellement
acquis que l'idée même d'une évasion des
capitaux apparît étrange et ne
représente plus pour certain que la
sanction bienvenue d'une finance
efficiente adressée à des débiteurs IR
responsable pourtant à l'âge de
l'offshore à l'âge de l'optimisation
fiscale systématique et les crises
financières c'est bien sur une industrie
financière au service de l'évasion des
capitaux pour elle-même ou pour ses
usagers qu'on doit s'interroger
l'évasion des capitaux c'est alors ce
phénomène multiforme et prédateur qui
permet de soustraire la richesse aux
quelques reliques de souveraineté des
États par lesquels ceuxci s'affiche
encore parfois comme les garants des
intérêts et d'un ordre public la
commission d'enquête n'a pas pu
envisager tous les chef d'évasion de
capitaux relevant de la finance elle a
particulièrement considéré l'évasion des
capitaux à finalité fiscale directement
ou à travers le blanchiment de la fraude
fiscale il faudra un jour revenir sur la
contribution sociale et économique du
secteur financier et se demander si
celui-ci présente dans les conditions
actuelles de son fonctionnement des
titres à absorber une part de plus en
plus conséquente de la valeur ajoutée au
risque d'en détruire régulièrement une
bonne partie peu sinon aucun des témoins
auditionnés par la Commission ne se sont
aventurés à contester le bien fondé de
son objet les personnalités
particulièrement qualifiées que nous
avons auditionné parmi lesquels l'ancien
directeur général du FMI et l'ancien
président de la Banque centrale
européenne notamment sont convenus que
la finance présente des risques de
fraude particulièrement aigus
elle réunit tous les attributs propices
aux fraudes subis ou commis par les
acteurs financiers eux-même observation
fondamentale vérifié par notre
commission l'opacité des circuits et les
R financier la vitesse des opérations la
disparition des frontières et des
distances dans une mobilité qui
contraste avec la fixité des espaces de
souveraineté nationale dans lesquelles
s'exerce l'action des contrôleurs compte
au nombre des attributs de la finance il
faut ajouter que la finance a un
formidable pouvoir de novation elle peut
substituer à des revenus taxables
d'autres revenus non taxés ou moins
taxés si elle n'a pas le pouvoir de
changer le plomb en or elle peut
réaliser l'opération inverse en
transformant l'or de la sphère
économique réel d'un pays en plomb pour
les administrations fiscales et plus
largement celles en charge des intérêts
publics les prix de transfert financiers
qui repose sur l'assiette considérable
des relations financières intr grroupes
les structurations des bilans
d'entreprisees dans les groupes et leurs
effets artificiels sur les revenus nets
qui fond de la contribution fiscale les
arbitrages réglementaires multiples
offerts par les techniques financières
parmi lesquels je voudrais citer ceux
d'actualité pouvant porter sur certaines
rémunérations salariales qui alter à la
contribution sociale ne sont que
quelques-unes des multiples
manifestations des potentialités
d'évasion des richesses par la
finance celle-ci repose aussi sur
l'extrême facilité qu'elle a de
dissimuler les richesses facilité
entretenue par l'industrie financière
qui s'est employé à se créer des zones
de droit sur mesure tous les grands
témoins auditionnés par la commission en
ont appelé à une nouvelle régulation de
la finance j'y vois le témoignage d'un
refus de l'impérialisme de la finance
aux dérives patentes il trouve des
expressions aussi variées que lesessort
du shadow banking cette finance des
financiers pour les financiers ou
l'intervention directe de banqu pour
façonner les législations de certains
pays de son côté le secret bancaire
absolu opposé aux règles les plus
démocratique n'est-il pas la
manifestation de la suprématie accordée
aux intérêts représentés par les
institutions financières sachons
également reconnaître qu'en cela l'offre
des financiers rejoint une demande
croissante d'évitement de l'impôt par
des élite mondialisée qui coïncid avec
les intérêts des acteurs financiers dans
un monde où les oligarchies financières
se se renforcent sous l'effet des
déséquilibres du partage des richesses
les oligopoles financiers se mettent au
diapason des attentes des ultra hauts
revenus leurs auxiliaires des
professions du droit et du chiffre
retirent une part importante de leur
rémunération de recettes visant à
optimiser astucieusement les revenus des
entreprises et des particuliers en les
soustrayant à la contribution commune
les lois que nous adoptons sont ainsi
régulièrement vidées de leur portée par
toute une infrastructure qui est payée
pour échapper à un pouvoir que nous
exerçons au nom du peuple dans ce monde
il est illusoire d'attendre les acteurs
financiers une quelconque
autorégulation l'évasion des capitaux
devient systémique quelle proposition
appréciable les institutions financières
ont-elles jamais avancé pour améliorer
leur conformité comment ne pas relever
l'absence de plainte de la profession
dans les cas avérés de fraude par des
banques concurrentes quand les mêmes
sanctionnent sans merci le plus petit
découvert que dire de l'utilisation sans
vergogne des juridiction à secret
bancaire et des États non coopératifs de
la multiplication des offres de
véhicules vantés pour leur potentialité
fiscale du déplacement entre pays des
avoirs consécutifs au durcissement des
règles touchant tel pays vers d'autres
destinations épargnées par lui de la
profusion des schémas de planification
fiscale agressive dont le nombre ne
cesse de croître d'après le ress lcement
qu'en fait
l'OCDE la commission d'enquête a eu à
connaître des situations individuelles
plus ou moins publiques témoignant
d'évidentes
transgressions chacun ici connaît peu ou
prou les dossiers HSBC UBS et d'autres
plus franco-français sans pouvoir entrer
dans les détails je puis témoigner que
les investigations auxquelles j'ai
procédé en ma qualité de rapporteur ont
pu conduire à des observations
singulières je m'interroge en
particulier sur le recours par de
nombreuses personnes morales à des
comptes à l'étranger gérer dans des
conditions apparemment destinées à les
dissimuler je relève encore qu'en
réponse à mon questionnaire certaines
grandes entreprises du CAC 40 sont allés
jusqu'à affirmer ne pouvoir être
concerné par telle liste désormais bien
connu quand en réalité elle se trouvait
être porté sur elle la commission de son
côté a pu prendre connaissance des cas
particuliers impliquant des
compensations financières plutôt
triviales mais pouvant concerner des
sommes considérables et qui lient le
grand banditisme aux fraudeurs fiscaux
c'est les comportements
micro-économiques aboutissent à des
formations macrofinancières monstrueuses
tel micro-état dépourvu du moindre début
d'une infrastructure de contrôle et
offrant des garanties de non
fiscalisation au long cours se retrouve
le 4e centre financier
international le déploiement des groupes
financiers dans les paradis bancaires et
les réseaux qu'il dessinent confère à
l'offshore une place de choix dans les
circuits financiers internationaux avec
tous les risques associés pour l'ordre
financier international la stabilité
financière mais aussi la conformité des
flux des intervenants et des échanges en
Europe elle-même n'est-ce pas le plus
petit État qui est aussi le plus grand
centre financier de gestion de fonds les
bermus ne sont-elles pas la plaque
tournante mondiale de l'assurance
combien de Bénéfic les captifs
constitués par les entreprises
françaises sur ce territoire
dégageent-ell chaque année monsieur le
ministre et combien cela coûte-t-il au
Trésor public les bénéfices entreprises
du CAC 40 réalisé à l'étranger ne
reflètent-il que les succès commerciaux
rencont rentré sur place ou admett-il
une part des bénéfices réalisés en
France et habilement transféré à
l'étranger à sa manière la commission
d'enquête a éprouveré les effets de
l'opacification entretenu par les
nébuleuses financières en réponse à une
question portant sur les activités les
bénéfices et les impôts à quités dans
une liste de territoire les banques
interrogées ont affirmé ne pouvoir
fournir ces éléments étrange réponse qui
contraste pour le moins avec les
informations qu'on s'attendrait voir
réunis par les établissements à la
pointe des techniques de gestion
d'autant plus étrange et je dirais même
inacceptable qu'il suffit de se reporter
à l'audition du président de la BNP
Paribas devant la commission d'enquête
du Sénat sur l'évasion fiscale
internationale l'an dernier pour se
persuader que ces données sont déjà
disponibles et qu'elles expliquent pour
beaucoup l'écart entre le taux
d'imposition nominale théorique des
dites entités et leur imposition
effective en France constat
soigneusement édulcoré dans un récent
rapport du Conseil des prélèvements
obligatoires rédigé il est vrai par un
rapport teur exerçant désormais ses
talents au service d'une grande banque
étrangère au centre du plus grand
scandale financier de ces derniers temps
oui décidément mieux connaître ce sera
déjà mieux combattre on le sait cette
condition appelle une coopération
internationale dont les défaillances
actuelles sont connus ces dernières
années des accords interétatiques ont
été présentés comme la manifestation
d'une mobilisation internationale pour
mieux défendre les droits légitimes des
états ce processus a particulièrement
consisté à s'assurer d'une coopération
mutuelle effective passant par des
échanges d'informations mais aussi dans
le champ de la lutte antiblanchiment qui
est le second pilier du combat contre
les flux illicites de capitaux par
l'adoption de normes communes supposé
répondre au défis du blanchiment la
vision idylique du coner des nations qui
tente à être diffusé par les
gouvernements est-elle vraiment deise
n'a-t-on pas assisté à un exercice
formel et doit-on pour l'avenir
s'attendre à mieux forcer d'observer que
sans être dénué d'utilité le Forum
mondial fiscal de l'OCDE ou les
conventions bilatéral n'ont pas atteint
leurs objectifs par exemple alors que
les résultats de la supervision exercé
par le forum ont conduit à vider les
différentes listes qui représentait
l'unique issue du processus laissant à
croire que la coopération fiscale avait
atteint un point satisfaisant la réalité
d'une faillite presque totale du système
actuel d'échange d'information à la
demande volontaire ou spontané s'est
imposé on privilégie désormais un
standard d'échange automatique
d'information qui est en effet de loin
préférable mais qui ne veut le moins
voudra-t-il vraiment le plus de quels
instruments sommes-nous dotés pour
contraindre les États RAL citron et il y
en a quelques-uns au sein même de
l'Union européenne à respecter le futur
nouveau standard la France mise en cause
par la Commission européenne
montre-t-elle toujours l'exemple comment
progresser sur ce terrain maintenant que
le Conseil constitutionnel a conforté
quelque part les paradis fiscaux nous
semblons attendre des États-Unis la
lumière ce qui n'est pas la hauteur de
ce qu'on attend légitimement de l'Europe
et pourrait bien affaiblir sa position
dans l'attractivité des capitaux un peu
de géostratégie financière ne nuirait
pas dans un contexte où les armes
réglementaires y compris dans le domaine
de la lutte contre l'évasion des
capitaux sont un outil de la guerre
financière internationale par ailleurs
toute une série d'inconnus planent sur
les processus en cours comment contrer
le recours à l' structure écran que la
4e directive antiblanchiment continue à
ignorer malgré l'évidence et les
révélations d'ofshore lex au printemps
dernier largement confirmé par les
documents que j'ai pu consulter dans mes
fonctions de rapporteur de la commission
cuit des progrès sur la voie d'une
action plus résolue en matière de
blanchiment quand des pans entiers sont
laissés à la discrétion des états voire
des des établissements financiers
eux-mêmes quit des sanctions effectives
contre les états ou les acteurs
financiers complices ou hauteur de
l'évasion des capitaux tant que les
justice européenne resteront dans une
passivité à laquelle les États-Unis ont
si vigoureusement renoncé alors des
annonces sur le fatka européen où en
sommes-nous de la révision de la
directive épargne on peut craindre en
somme que le droit international ne
demeure encore une fois au gré des
rapports de force alternativement une
loi douce sans effet appréciable ou une
loi dure appliquée selon leurs intérêts
par les pays les plus forts au nombre
desquels l'Europe ne se comptera pas
cette crainte peut s'étendre aux
dispositions législatif que nous
adoptons l'abondance de normes ne ne
doit pas être le cache misère d'une
action qui doit être toujours exemplaire
nous avons beaucoup légiféré ces
dernières années pour renforcer les
moyens de la lutte contre les flux
illicites des capitaux nous manquons du
recul pour faire le bilan complet de ces
lois pour certains dispositifs en
revanche il existe déjà des motifs de
perplexité tel est le cas des régimes
durcissant la législation fiscale envers
les États non coopératifs tel est aussi
le cas d'un certain nombre de retenus à
la source remise en cause par la
juridiction européenne n'en ira-t-il pas
de même avec le registre des trusts qui
pourrait être souhaitable et conditionné
à la bonne volonté des États étrangers
les conventions fiscales ont-elles
toujours permis d'accéder aux
informations nécessaires l'élargissement
du dispositif tracf a-t-il abouti à une
lutte plus efficace contre le
blanchiment et contre la fraude fiscale
il n'y a pas jusqu'à l'accentuation très
bienvenue des peines et des moyens
d'investigation qui ne soulèv de telles
questions sur leurs prolongements
effectifs au vu des pratiques actuelles
la guerre contre l'évasion des capitaux
est un art tout d'exécution nous
préconisons sans doute des réformes à
dimension législative il nous faudra
d'abord réduire l' syymétrie
d'information dont abusent les acteurs
financiers en élargissant les
obligations de dévoilement d'information
pour certains produits financiers
notamment d'assurance pour certains
schémas fiscaux l'Assemblée nationale
vient de le voter récemment contre l'
vie du gouvernement comme nous l'avons
fait pour les comptes des banques dans
les paystiers sur ce point nous devrons
veiller à ce que les choix concernant le
périmètre de consolidation des banques
qui sert de référence n'altère pas la
portée de l'information à laquelle nous
les avons obligé et élargir cette
obligation à les entreprises non
financières le statut des lanceurs
d'alertes qui a été amélioré tandis
qu'un statut du repenti a été organisé
pourra sans doute l'être encore pour
couvrir des situations plus réalistes et
mieux sécuriser leurs perspectives
concrète par ailleurs il nous faut mieux
de formaliser l'engagement des organes
sociaux sur la conformité fiscale des
entreprises et associer les institutions
représentatives du personnel à ces
sujets il nous faudra également résoudre
par la voie législative un certain
nombre de conflits d'intérêts qui voit
des contrôleurs placés sous la
suggestion économique des contrôlés
comme c'est le cas des commissaires aux
comptes ou laisser sans statut
suffisamment protecteur comme c'est le
cas des personnels chargés de la
conformité dans les institutions
financières nous devrons également
modifier la composition de certains
collèges de superviseurs qui compent des
personnalités actives dans entreprises
ayant des liens commerciaux ou
financiers avec des entités soumises à
leur contrôle ou à leur sanctions il
nous faudra aussi mieux responsabiliser
les facilitateurs de la fraude fiscale
internationale par un appareil de
sanction adapté à leur participation à
des fraudes qui ne leur vaut aujourd'hui
que l'impunité c'est le sens de la
recommandation consistant à créer une
infraction pour incitation à la fraudte
fiscale des moyens d'enquête
supplémentaires ont été accordé au
contrôle fiscal sans doute faudra-t-il
en doter également la CPR en s'inspirant
du régime prévu pour l'Autorité des
marchés financiers mais plus que de
nouvelles normes c'est à un
fonctionnement efficace des services et
à leur bonne application qu'il faut
s'attacher plus de cohésion et plus de
fermeté un certain nombre de dispositifs
légaux sont désamorcés par des choix
condamnables pourquoi adopter une
doctrine si restrictive de détermination
des États non coopératifs dont témoigne
encore la liste dernièrement arrêtée et
qu'elle neutralise les régimes
pénalisant les paradis fiscaux n'est-ce
pas adresser un blancin au développement
de la finance offshore pourquoi estimer
que la Suisse et son secret bancaire est
un état impeccable en matière de lutte
antiblanchiment quand de nombreuses
affaires démontrre tout le contraire
est-il réellement acceptable que
l'Autorité de contrôle prudentiel et de
résolution soyz lié par le secret
professionnel à l'égard des les services
fiscaux quand elle exerce des
responsabilités importantes dans le
combat contre le blanchiment notamment
de fraude fiscale pourquoi refuser au
contrôle fiscal d'interroger Tracfin sur
les signalements dont cet organisme
pourrait disposer solution véritablement
cafcenne puisque dans le même temps les
cas sensibles sont naturellement
signalés au ministre qui supérieur
hiérarchique de la Direction générale
des finances publiques se trouve forcé à
un clévage dangereux et qu'on devine
pouvoir être particulièrement
inconfortable en certaines circonstances
tout toujours à propos de Tracfin ne
devrait-on pas en cohérence avec l'arrêt
talemont lui ouvrir la faculté de saisir
l'autorité judiciaire en cas de soupçon
de blanchimement de fraude fiscale
plutôt que de le lui interdire au-delà
de ces différents aspects il nous faut
tendre vers une action opérationnelle
beaucoup plus clair et résolu les moyens
ne sont pas à la hauteur des missions
les différentes affaires survenues ces
dernières années ont absorbé une
proportion considérable des ressources
des services nous l'avons constaté et
nous nous interrogeons sur l'adéquation
des capacités de traitement des dossiers
de régularisation qui semblent devoir
être débordé en l'état de force en
l'état des forces quand on contrôle
fiscal ordinaire les moyens du contrôle
d'entité dont certaines comptent un
total de bilan équivalent au PIB de
notre pays sont-ils vraiment au niveau
de même Tracfin tente à être submergé
par les signalements ce qui conduit à
des apurements sauvages de dossier et
que dire des moyens de la justice et des
services d'enquête combien de dossiers
ont-ils été abandonnés je m'interroge
par exemple sur le devenir des documents
confiés par l'ACP au service de la
douane judiciaire concernant les
personnes impliquées dans l'affaire UBS
pouvez-nous nous informer monsieur le
ministre sur les diligences effectuées
et leur suite au-delà de celles connues
concernant les mises en examen des
établissements eux-mêmes insuffisance de
moyens mais aussi parfois insuffisance
de fermeté est-il vraiment acceptable
inaccessible pardon aux autorités de
contrôle prudentiel comme elle l'indique
de connaître finement les opérations des
banques dans des juridictions où elles
sont exemples de contrôle locaux dign de
ce nom peut-on se satisfaire que la
seule obligation pesant sur elle quand
les murs locales leur interdisent de
satisfaire aux exence de la lutte contre
le blanchiment soit d'en informer les
autorités françaises qui doivent tout de
même le savoir déjà celle-ci qui
conselle ne recourir qu'à un contrôle
sur base sociale consolidé
nécessairement aveugle aux échanges
intragroupes ne devrait-elle pas alors
mieux sanctionner les situations où le
contrôle de la maison m est
manifestement manifestement défaillant
pourquoi loin d'aboutir à ce résultat
l'examen par la commission des sanctions
de laacp peut-il permettre à une grande
banque française d'échapper à l'grièes
de ce type au motif de l'absence d'un
accord formel de coopération entre l'ACP
et son homologue malgré le consentement
ponctuel donné par celui-ci la
commission d'enquête a pu également
relever que les contrôles effectués dans
l'affaire UBS avaient été de la part de
la CP pour le moins poussif je n'ai pas
trouvé trac d'importants éléments de
cette affaire dans les documents dont
j'ai pu prendre connaissance et par
lesquels l'administration tient le
fichier des personnes soupçonné de
dissimuler les avoirs à l'étranger il
est vrai que ce fichier ne comporte pas
davantage la mention de personnes dont
il est avéré aujourd'hui de leur propre
aveux qu'elle se trouve dans cette
situation quand sanctionnera-t-on
certaines professions du chiffre et du
droit qui ne joue pas le jeu des
signalement à traquef puisque ni la loi
ni la pédagogie ne semble suffire quand
s'inquiétera-t-on réellement de la
faible vigueur du dispositif quand des
personnes politiquement exposées sont en
cause je conclurai moi aussi sur les
questions du verrou de Bery
malheureusement pas directement présenté
ce matin je le déplore j'ai la
conviction que cette anomalie attribue
une sorte de raison d'État fiscal devra
un jour céder les technicien la défendre
au nom de l'efficacité des redressements
ce n'est pas très bon signe puisque
c'est reconnaître que notre contrôle
fiscal est insuffisamment assuré sur ces
base est-ce par ailleurs vraiment
crédible entre les droits constatés et
les droits recouvrés quel est l'écart il
est sûr que ce monopole affecte les
principes du droit le mépris des
obligations de l'article 40 du code de
procédure pénale en témoigne il était
également sûr qu'il jette la suspicion
sur l'action publique les quelques
avancées de la loi contre la fraude
fiscale ne suffiront pas à la lever le
verou de Bery participe ainsi d'une
opacité de l'action publique antifraude
qui nuit à la confiance et ne favorise
pas son efficacité don est presque
terminé monsieur le Président reprenant
une proposition de la commission
d'enquête sur l'évasion fiscale
internationale nous souhaitons que soit
créé un Haut Commissariat à la
protection des intérêts financiers publ
répondant aux meilleures pratiques de
l'évaluation à l'heure où le Premier
ministre on a appelé à la réforme
fiscale nos institutions doivent être
complétées pour mieux veiller à la
conformité fiscale de tous au service de
l'égalité devant les prélèvements
obligatoires je vous
remercie dans la suite du débat la
parole est aux orateurs des
groupes tout d'abord madame Corine
bouchou pour le groupe
écologiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
le Président de la Commission après la
saison 1 nous avons la saison
2 je me félicite de l'ampleur du travail
de la réceptivité des membres de la
Commission on peut dire de la bonne
humeur qui a régné lors de nos travaux
malgré un sujet qui ne prête pas à
sourire la collaboration des personnes
auditionnées a été également de qualité
et la variété des pistes retenues
structuré autour de de axes mieux
connaître et mieux combattre nous sommes
nous semble d'une grande
opportunité c'est en 2008 suite à une
série de faillite bancaire que le grand
public découvre la nocivité des paradis
fiscaux véritable angle mort de la
mondialisation financière dans lequell
les entreprises multinationales et les
riches particuliers dissimilent leurs
activités pour échapper au fisqu à la
justice ou aux autorités de régulation
du marché les paradis fiscaux ne sont
certainement pas les seuls responsables
de la crise financière de 2008 cependant
ils y ont très largement contribué nous
en parlerons ce matin la multiplication
des affaires qui font apparaître au
grand jour ce processus qui se nourrit
du secret ne manque pas de créer les
mois et l'indignation de l'opinion
publique dont l'attente se fait de plus
en plus pressente et pendant ce temps-là
monsieur le ministre le populisme croit
et l'extrême droite en fait son miel la
dérégulation du marché est pointé du
droit du doigt ainsi un consensus a
émergé et il porte sur l'échec d'un
désarmement institutionnel qui
laisserait la finance à un état de
pseudo nature il recouvre aussi le
constat d'une nécessaire action pour
lutter contre l'autre grande plaie du
moment la contribution des circuits
financiers à l'essort du crime dans les
processus de blanchiment oui mes chers
collègues la mafia existe nous ne
l'avons pas rencontré frontalement mais
notamment lors d'une visite à Nanterre
nous avons pu constater que ce que nous
étudions là est extrêmement lié aux
mafias ces mafias sont elles-même relier
un certain nombre de grands secteurs le
secteur bancaire le secteur du BTP
notamment appelons un chat un chat alors
que dès 2008 de nombreuses mesures
internationales avaient été annoncées
suite au G20 notamment les banques
premières utilisatrices de ces
territoires opaques n'ont pas vraiment
modifié leur pratique selon un rapport
du CCFD datant de 2012 BNP pariba et la
Société Générale et le Crédit Agricole
comptait 513 filiales dans les paradis
fiscaux contre 494 en 2010 donc loin de
s'améliorer la situation s'aggrave les
établissements financiers ont bien
quitté certains paradis fiscaux mais
seulement ceux de la liste grise de
l'OCDE qui n'en comporte d'ailleurs plus
que trois ainsi que huit autres désignés
comme tels par la France il est de notre
responsabilité ici d'éliminer les
échappatoires à l'impôt y compris des
banques dont le taux de contribution
fiscale reste difficile à évaluer du
fait de leurs activités offshore et de
leur internationalisation et qui pour la
plupart pratique des opérations
d'optimisation fiscale plus ou moins
agressive en 2012 lorsque Pascal Canfin
publiaé ce que les banques vous disent
et pourquoi il ne faut jamais les croire
un ouvrage que je vous recommande
vivement celui-ci constatait une
capacité de lobbying extrêmement
puissante des institutions financière il
n'y avait pas jusqu'à une date
relativement récente de contrepouvoir
organisé à ce sujet cependant les choses
ont évolué avec la création de Finance
Watch à Bruxelles ou encore la
mobilisation de longue dates de
certaines onz sur ONG sur le sujet comme
Oxfam et le CCFD leurs compétences sont
très vite montées en puissance sur ces
sujets et elles sont aujourd'hui des
forces de proposition pertinentes et
respecté aussi un contrepouvoir citoyen
s'organise trop lentement mais il faut
louer son travail il réussit à
décortiquer les discours techniques et
complexes des banques à le critiquer et
à se faire entendre un peu dans les
médias il est selon nous essentiel en
termes démocratiqu de faire vivre ce
débat citoyen autour de la finance de
ses méfits et de les évasion
fiscale la France n'est pas en reste
puisque le contexte législatif progresse
sur le sujet mais trop longement à notre
goût la loi de transparence des
activités bancaires votées en juillet
2013 a un peu renforcé la lutte contre
les paradis fiscaux et le blanchiment
des capitaux notamment avec l'obligation
de transparence sur les activités pays
par pays en permettant la mise en œuvre
de l'échange automatique d'information
en matière fiscale et en renforçant les
pouvoirs de tracfine ainsi que les
obligations des personnes assujetties à
la lutte contre le blanchiment des
capitaux et le financement du terrorisme
la loi sur la fraude quant à elle a
permis de saluer deux avancées qui ont
été porté par les écologistes à
l'Assemblée nationale d'une part la mise
en place d'un registre public des trust
et d'autre part la meilleure protection
des lanceurs d'alertes le cas d'Hervé
Falciani exinformaticien de la banque
HSBC nous rappelle l'importance de
protéger les lanceurs d'alertes qui
fournissent au fisque français les
informations sur ces cas d'évasion
fiscale de très grande ampleur la loi de
finances 2004 14 a présenté quelques
mesures afin de compléter le dispositif
de lutte contre la fraude et l'évasion
fiscale cependant les mesures proposées
par le groupe écologiste pour lutter
contre l'optimisation fiscale des très
grandes entreprises n'ont pas été
entendu je le regrette ici je vous
rappelle qu'il s'agissait d'un
amendement obligeant les entreprises
enfin nécessitant que les entreprises
qui seraient condamnées pour fraude
fiscale ne seraient plus éligible au
crédit d'impôt ça nous semble
complètement élémentaire de ne pas
donner des primes à ceux qui trichent et
l'autre mesure proposait d'aligner le
régime de déductibilité des charges des
États à fiscalité privilégié sur celui
des États non coopératifs ces deux
amendements ont été rejetés la volonté
politique selon nous est une notion
centrale elle permettra la
reconstruction du lien de confiance
entre les citoyens et la politique et
les politiques en terme de démocratie
politique et de reprise en main de la
mondialisation folle au niveau financier
alors comment procéder nous avons
additionné avec satisfaction Denis
Robert qui a beaucoup contribué sur ce
dossier l'affaire Clearstream lui nous
dit et c'est peut-être une piste pour
une saison 3 il convient plutôt de
s'interroger sur la manière dont les
transactions sont opérées plutôt que de
traquer indéfiniment etvèement les
paradis fiscaux il compare les flux
financiers à des autoroutes où les
banques sont libres de circuler sans
aucune immatriculation selon lui pour
gagner la bataille contre le
noircissement de l'économie et les trou
noir de la finance il faut former de
véritables brigades autoroutières où des
ratards informatiques permettrai d'
intercepter les véhicules en infraction
qui circulent sur ces
autoroutes je ne vais pas lister ici
l'ensemble des propositions qui ont été
faites par cette commission saison 2
mais selon nous la réflexion menée
autour de l'élargissement du champ
d'intervention des services judiciaaires
mérite une attention toute particulière
de la part de notre
gouvernement finalement mes chers
collègues en conclusion de cette saison
2 moi je me demande si ce dossier sur
l'évasion fiscale n'est pas que l'arbre
qui cache la forêt et si le vrai
problème n'était pas l'insuffisance d'un
système devenu complètement fou qui
tourne à vide et je vous renvoie à
l'ouvrage extrêmement pertinent de
Monsieur nollo crise financière pourquoi
les gouvernements ne font rien et si la
fraude et l'évasion fiscale n'était que
le symptôme de notre système devenu fou
je vous remercie de votre
attention dans la suite du débat la
parole est maintenant à Madame Nathalie
Goulet pour le groupe udi
UC bonjour
euh monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Président de la commission
d'enquête monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers
collègues nous sommes 12 en séance pour
un sujet aussi important autant dire que
nous sommes entre nous et nous fêtons
aujourd'hui le premier anniversaire de
la Déclaration de jume Cahusac au terme
desquel il déclarait qu'il n'avait pas
de compte à
l'étranger ce 5 décembre est donc a
marqué d'une première bougie hier
monsieur le ministre le Sénat a battu
l'assemblée 1 à 0 il y avait un sénateur
moi et zéro députés à la présentation du
rapport annuel de Transparency
internationale qui visait la
transparence de la vie publique et
l'évasion fiscale euh évidemment ce
rapport repose un certain nombre de
problèmes puisqu'il parle de perception
de la corruption de perception de la
fraude et dans le tsunami de l'affaire
cahusa il est clair qu'il faudra plus
qu'un train de mesures pour rétablir la
confiance et c'est vrai que l'affaire
Cahusac a produit des textes législatifs
on en a parlé des commissions d'enquête
on en a
parlé et je vais vous parler moi des
lanceurs d'alertes et de la formation je
croyais que Bernard casazenuf serait au
banc et ne voulant pas le contrarier je
ne voulais pas parler du verrou de Bercy
mais puisque vous êtes là monsieur le
ministre je vais vous en parler
et juste un mot le verrou de Bery a fait
l'objet de très nombreux débats le 16 et
le 17 juillet dernier euh
malheureusement nous n'avons pas pu
adopt les dispositions de bon sens et de
transparence qu'avait préparé notre
collègue Anziani au nom de la commission
des lois et nous le regrettons euh moi
je voulais vous dire que
comme les murs de Jéricho ce verrou de
Bery finira un jour ou l'autre par
sombrer et à mon avis sous le coup d'une
question préalable de constitutionnalité
la première a été déposée le 29 novembre
ça n'a pas fonctionné mais je pense que
le combat continue et que sous l'angle
de la question préalable de
constitutionnalité le verrou de Bery
sautera et il résistera moins me
semble-t-il aux juridictions qu'il n'a
pu résister au parlementaires je
voudrais donc vous parler des lanceurs
d'alertes il existe malheureusement
monsieur le ministre aucune convention
au CDE pour les lanceurs d'alertes et je
crois que que ce serait important que la
France puisse porter euh ce projet d'une
convention OCDE pour les les lanceurs
d'alertes euh dans un pays comme la
Suisse la vérité est pratiquement
illégale d'ailleurs elle est pas
pratiquement illégale elle est illégale
euh l'exemple de Pierre Condamin Gerbier
avait fait un très grand nombre de
déclarations qui se sont avéré
absolument exactes des son retour en
Suisse il a été incarcéré monsieur le
rapporteur et moi-même avons été
d'ailleurs soutenir euh ses défenseurs
on retrouve le même problème pour
d'autres lanceurs d'alerte Nicole Marie
Meyer expert attaché à transparency
internationale a déclaré hier lors de la
présentation du rapport la France est ce
pays paradoxal ou un ministre du Budget
pratique la fraude fiscale mais où un
commandant de police est révoqué pour
avoir signalé un usage illicite de
fichier par son administration un
diplomate licencié pour avoir rendu à sa
hiérarchie un rapport confidentiel sur
des dysfonctionnements financiers avéré
un fonctionnaire territorial menacé pour
avoir signalé en interne des marchés
publics
irréguliers par ailleurs on assiste à
une limitation de la coopération
internationale et du
multiatéralisme en matière de lutte
contre la fraude et l'évasion fiscale le
cas de la Suisse est un cas absolument
typique les lanceurs d'alertes ne sont
pas les seuls à souffrir des carences de
l'action internationale l'action
multilatérale en matière de lutte contre
la fraude fiscale reste suffisante et
superficielle voire hypocrite y compris
dans les enceintes de l'OCDE comme je le
disais tout à l'heure Pascal saintamment
a beau dire qu'il existe plus de secret
bancaire en Suisse et que la coopération
et l'échange d'information progresse la
réalité est tout autre au plan
strictement juridique le droit suisse
tout entier est tourné vers la
protection des banques le Conseil
fédéral suisse a renoncé en septembre
dernier à sanctionner pénalement des
banquiers dont l'action aurait été peu
scrupuleuse du côté du droit positif les
articles 200 271 272 273 du code pénal
suisse interdisent toute intrusion d'une
puissance étrangère qui serait contraire
aux lois traditions et intérêt de la
Suisse cette législation notamment de
fondement sert de fondement à toute
négociation fiscale entre la Suisse et
le reste du monde notamment les
États-Unis quant à l'article 273 relatif
aux peines sanctionnant l'intelligence
économique il suffit de le lire pour
démontrer qu'en Suisse la vérité en
matière d'évasion fiscale et de fraude
fiscale internationale est illégale dans
de telles conditions on imagine
également les chances de succès d'une
commission rogatoire internationale pour
interroger les responsables locaux du BS
ou d'HSBC sans parler de l'entreprise
qui administre le port-fanc de Genève il
serait urgent à cet égard monsieur le
ministre que les autorités françaises
lancent une commission rogatoire inter
interrogeant Raoul Veil l'ancien
président du BS qui est actuellement
incarcéré en Italie car en Italie on
peut l'interroger dès qu'il va être de
retour en Suisse on pourra plus le faire
par ailleurs nous sommes passés à côté
d'un problème majeur de l'évasion
fiscale qui concerne les ports francs en
Suisse vous avez monsieur le ministre 17
port-fanc en Suisse grand comme 25
terrains de football anti-chambre ou
garde manger des banques suisses où
s'entasse or et œuvre d'art gage de
transactions multiples et varié dans
l'anonymat confortable une simple
consigne
euh reste euh l'impératif de formation à
la lutte contre la fraude fiscale c'est
la proposition numéro 12 de notre
commission d'enquête de nombreuses zones
d'ombre pourrai être soulevé mais il
semble euh de ce point de vue que nous
sommes évidemment dans la guerre de
l'OBU et du blindage qu'il faut former
les personnels et qu'il faut créer me
semble-t-il un centre important pour les
étudiants et pour le personnel chargé de
contrôler la fraudte fiscale euh Michel
auan lors de nos auditions s'en est ému
puisqu'il existe en en Grande-Bretagne
deux structures de la sorte et qu' n'en
existe pas en France seulle l'école
doctorale de parien travaille sur ces
sujets en France mais dans une optique
universitaire et non pas dans une
logique opérationnelle il y a un manque
crucial monsieur le ministre de
formation crucial madame coupé soubéran
également dans notre commission
d'enquête a pointé les difficultés
d'accès de retraitement des données
statistiques de l'in
quant à Hervé falcani on en a déjà parlé
tout à l'heure il a déclaré que
l'administration ne disposait pas des
moyens humains pour analyser
l'information qu'elle avait à sa
disposition on tourne toujours un peu en
en rond c'est vrai que notre
administration tout le monde le monde
entier nous l'envie et qu'évidemment il
faut lui rendre un hommage appuyé mais
que néanmoins compte tenu de la rapidité
avec laquelle la technique de fraude
évolue il faut aussi faire évoluer les
techniques de formation d'après Noël
ponce également interrogé dans dans le
cadre de notre commission les techniques
de renseignement relativ à la lutte
contre la fraude doivent évoluer
qualitativement pour appréhender les
évolutions techniques et leur lien avec
la grande criminalité les modèles
informatiques ne peuvent pas tout faire
Dominique stroskan avait d'ailleurs fait
état de leur défaut de conception aussi
il est nécessaire d'avoir davantage de
personnel ça on le sait et on le déplore
malheureusement nous n'avons pas pu
examiner la deuxième partie de la loi de
finances nous aurions tous voulu euh
augmenter et oui monsieur le ministre je
comprends votre votre déception c'est
aussi la nôtre et ce n'est pas notre
fait euh il est nécessaire donc d'avoir
davantage de personnel formé à la
connaissance des méthodes de fraude
fiscale afin de
prévenir l'inertie dans la création de
certains dispositif législatif on pourra
voter toutes les lois qu'on veut si on n
pas le personnel adéquate pour les
former le personnel pour assurer le
suivi le personnel pour enquêter et
traiter les données je crois que que
tout ce que nous pourrons faire ici et
nous sommes tous mobilisés monsieur le
ministre contre ce fléo qui est
l'évasion fiscale nous n'arons pas à
avoir de bons résultat
euh j'en auraiis pratiquement terminé
puisque j'ai parlé en quittant mes notes
ce qui veut dire que je sais plus du
tout où j'en suis mais ça n'a pas
beaucoup
d'importance je voudrais vous dire
Monsieur le Ministre que j'ai
été nous avons été particulièrement
déçus du refus du président du Sénat de
CR dans cette maison une délégation
permanente dédiée à la protection des
intérêts financiers de l'État c'était
une de nos propositions du premier de la
première commission d'enquête parce que
je pense qu'il est important que nous
puissions suivre en matière législative
en matière financière en matière fiscale
de façon constante l'évolution de notre
législation et de la jurisprudence le
président du Sénat qui avait été saisi
par le le premier enfin le président de
la première commission d'enquête
Philippe dominti avec une lettre que
nous avions tous signé euh et qui lui
demandait la création de cette
délégation le président a refusé de
créer cette délégation à l'intérieur du
Sénat ça aurait permis au Sénat
d'accroître son pouvoir de contrôle et
surtout son pouvoir de suivi je pense
qu'il s'agit là d'une pression amicale
de la commission des finances qui a
peut-être voulu garder la main sur sur
ce dossier je crois que c'est
regrettable et je crois qu'à la
prochaine session parlementaire il
faudra monsieur le Président de la
commission d'enquête monsieur le
rapporteur remettre ce sujet sur le
tapis car je crois que c'est très
important que nous puissions suivre ces
dossiers de façon régulière et constante
dans notre
maison donc monsieur le ministre nous
sommes tous
mobilisés les marges de progrès sont
extrêmement importantes et je
voudrais profiter de la présence de
philippe Dallier pour le féliciter du
travail qu'il a fait avec notre collègue
de montolfier sur la fraude à la TVA
mais je vous en prie mon cher collègue
ce sera votre le grand mérite d'avoir
été là ce matin pour nous écouter sur ce
sujet important mais de toute façon le
rapport est tout à fait excellent et
nous avions soulevé à de très nombreuses
reprises dans nos deux commissions
d'enquête les fraudes à la TVA et la
marge de progrès extrêmement importante
qu'il y a donc je crois que augmenter la
TVA sur les centres équestres ce n'est
pas bien mais la marge de progrès pour
le coup sur la vraie fraude à la TVA
c'est important monsieur le ministre
sachez que nous sommes absolument tous
solidaires et mobilisés sur ce sujet et
je vous remercie de votre
attention dans la suite du débat la
parole est à Monsieur Jacques Chiron
pour le groupe
socialiste
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues la commission
d'enquête sur le rôle des acteurs
financiers dans l'évasion des capitaux
nous a permis de prolonger le travail du
Sénat sur l'évasion fiscale après une
première commission d'enquête qui avait
en 2012 préciser l'ampleur de ce fléo
tout en proposant de nombreux outils
pour le maîtriser au terme de 6 mois
d'audition d'une cinquantaine de
personnalités diverses issues des
secteurs de la banque de la finance des
institutions financière et de la
régulation nous avons rendu en octobre
dernier un rapport qui recense les
opportunités d'évasion des capitaux
permises par le fonctionnement de la
finance et formule 34 propositions une
nouvelle fois adopté à l'unanimité et je
veux profiter et je veux en profiter
pour remercier le rapporteur et le
président de la commission pour leur
écoute de chacun d'entre nous qui a
permis cette unanimité ces propositions
qui nous que nous avons adopté
vise à combler les lacunes dans la
gouvernance des systèmes de contrôle
existants à développer la supervision
des institutions et à élargir le champ
d'intervention des autorités judiciaires
comme l'intitulier de notre rapport le
rappelle notre objectif est de mieux
connaître pour mieux
combattre notre première mission pour
être efficace face à l'opacité de la
circulation des des richesses et donc de
remporter la bataille de l'information
la complexité des infr structure
financière et la la fragmentation des
espaces de souveraineté ne ne facilite
pas la tâche nous l'avons tous dit par
rapport à nos travaux de 2012 il est
donc nécessaire d'affirmer notre
diagnostic et de porter une attention
particulière sur les liens entre la
finance ses acteurs ses produits et
l'évasion des capitaux parmi les 34
propositions que nous formulons je
souhaiterais comme je l'ai déjà fait
lors du débat relatif aux conventions
international insister sur la
proposition numéro 18 celle consistant à
instaurer un fatka Européen les mesures
prises au niveau national sont
indispensables mais insuffisantes face à
un phénomène financier qui dépasse
largement les
frontières je salue néanmoins le projet
de loi relatif à la lutte contre la
fraude fiscale et à la grande
délinquence économique et financière que
nous avons voté en parallèle de nos
travaux elle va permettre de renforcer
l'efficacité de la lutte contre la
corruption et la fraude notamment en
donnant des moyens nouveaux à
l'administration même si quelquefois on
pense qu'ils ne sont pas encore assez
important et je souscris à cette à cette
constatation notamment en donnant et à
la à l'administration fiscale et à
l'autorité judiciaire qui seront toutes
deux dotter de nouveaux outils
juridiques leur permettant de mieux
détecter les anomanies et les fraudes
potentielles
de surmonter l'hostilité ou l'inertie
des acteurs récalcitran et de
sanctionner plus sévèrement la décision
du Conseil constitutionnel nous l' vous
vous l'avez dit avant moi qui même si
elle a reconnu le critère d'une amende
calculée en pourcentage que ce que ce
calcul n'est pas en lui-même anti
inconstitutionnel affaiblit c'est sûr la
lutte contre la fraude des personnes
morales mais seule la généralisation à
l'échelle européenne d'un dispositif
équip et efficace peut permettre de
franchir une nouvelle étape décisive en
obligeant les banques ou les États à
procéder à un échange automatique et
exhaustif d'information fiscale sous
peine d'une retenue à la source de leur
flux financier nous pourrions également
nous pourrions alors réellement faire
reculer le secret bancaire tout en
facilitant le travail de
l'administration fiscale en effet cette
dernière est parfois dépourvue face au
manque de col caboration de certains
pays qui ne répondent pas à nos demandes
de renseignement et notre collègue l'a
bien a bien insisté concernant la Suisse
suite à suite à nos auditions nous avons
également appris que même certaines
banques attendent la généralisation de
l'échange automatique
d'information l'instauration d'un fatka
Européen ne doit pas se limiter à la
généralisation d'une clause d'échange
automatique par la révision des
directives européennes sur l'épargne de
2003 et sur la coopération
administrative de 2011 au sein de la
commission d'enquête il est proposé
d'aller plus loin et d'étendre la
communication des informations bancaires
à toutes les banques du monde ayant une
présence en Europe sous peine d'une
retenue à la source de leur bénéfice cet
accord devra cette fois se faire sans
surc sans période dérogatoire et dans le
les mêmes termes entre tous les états la
force de l'Union a 27 permettrait
ensuite de de négocier une une
convention fiscale notamment avec la
Suisse à la hauteur des standards
internationaux et non en hord de
disperser comme les accords rubiic
bilatéraux bilatéraux voulaient le faire
l'union européenne a jusqu'ici été trop
tolérante à l'égard de pays qui bloquent
les tentatives de lever du secret
bancair et qui sont pour certains des
refuges accueillants pour les grands
groupes industriels et leur ation
fiscale c'est notamment le cas du
Luxembourg voisin concernant les leaders
remondiaux de
l'économie numérique tant pour la TVA
d'ailleurs que pour relies je note
néanmoins que ces derniers mois de très
nombrebreux signaux encourageant dans
l'évolution des mentalités et la
coopération
internationale arrive sous l'effet de la
crise financière et bancaire qui a mise
en évidence le caractère plus que jamais
inadmissible de l' de l' de l'incivisme
fiscal des particuliers et et des et des
entreprises la lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale internationale est depuis
plusieurs mois présente à l'ordre du
jour des principales instantces de
décision à l'échelle mondiale et
européenne en premier lieu l'échec des
accords Rubic montre que le seuil de
tolérance face à la politique de
d'opacité financière notamment en
Allemagne ou au Royaume-Uni a largement
évolué dans le bon sens les pays du G G8
réunis en juin tout comme ceux du G20
réunis début septembre à
Saint-Pétersbourg ont réaffirmé avec
force leur souhait commun de mettre en
place l'échange automatique
d'information fiscale une échéange fixé
à la fin 2015 a même été régulièrement
cité après les premières petites
avancées de pays comme la Suisse
l'Autriche et le Luxembourg concernant
le secret bancaire ou encore la
directive épargne c'est un nouveau pas
en avant vers la transparence et
l'équité fiscale qu' nous faut vraiment
je dirais forcer par ailleurs je me
réjouis que le G20 a pris en compte les
recommandations de l'OCDE relative à la
taxation des multinationales notamment
dans le
domaine numérique qui peuvent aisément
se soustraire à l'impôt enfin l'Union
européenne avance également à petit pas
vers la révision de la directive épargne
et à adopté une directive bientôt
effective qui renforce la coopération
administrative entre état confronté que
la comme la plupart de nos partenaires
européens à l'exigence de redressement
de nos comptte public notre pays a pris
toute sa part dans ce mouvement pour
faire revenir sur son territoire les
ressources qui lui sont dues nos
représentants ont porté à l'échelle
européenne et mondiale cette ambition de
justice et d'équité qui peut permettre à
terme de faire disparaître le secret
bancaire et faire reculer massivement
les pratiques d'évasion et
d'optimisation au plan interne si le
gouvernement a mis en place 60 mesures
fortes au sein d'un projet de loi
volontariste que nous avons voté il faut
également noter que la circulaire du
mois de juin dernier prise par le
ministre délégué au Budget Bernard
casazenu a permis en 4 mois d'augmenter
significativement le nombre de dossiers
de régularisation c'est prês de 8500
fraudeurs c'est le dernier chiffre que
j'ai entendu soit plus du double que
lors des 4 années précédentes qui se
sont présenté auprès de l'administration
fiscale conséquence directes des mesures
gouvernemental cela traduit la peur qui
se développe face à la pression
nationale et internationale face au
maill d'un filet qui chaque jour se
resserre cela montre la tendance que la
tendance S
là-dessus je suis sûrement plus
optimiste que mes que les précédents
orateurs bon donc cela montre que la
tendance
s'inverse que les efforts engagés
insécurisent les fraudeurs et
introduisent le doute entre le rapport
risque encouru et bénéfice est
compté chers collègues les Tau se
resserre mais la bataille naturellement
est loin d'être encore gagnée un certain
nombre des so 61 propositions que nous
avions formulé lors de la Commission d'
enquête sur l'évasion fiscale
internationale en 2012 ont été mis en
œuvre d'autres sont à l'étude je
souhaite qu'à nouveau notre voix soit
entendue que nos que nos proposition soi
traduite dans la législation et dans nos
appareils de contrôle le Sénat est
pleinement dans son rôle de surveillance
de contrôle et d'évaluation dans cette
mission au service du pays un pays dans
lequel chacun souhaite que la justice
fiscale existe et que et dans lequel
chacun doit contribuer en fonction de
ses moyens à la solidarité nationale
enfin je et j'en conclurai ainsi je me
réjouis de l'émergence de net d'un
consensus d'un Consus consensus national
qui se dégage au-delà des sensibilités
politiques comme en témoigne l'unanimité
de nos deux rapports pour qu'enfin le
monde de la finance soit mieux encé
encadré face à l'urgence de redresser
nos comptes publics face à l'évasion
face au blanchiment face à l'opacité du
système financier nous ne réussirons que
si nous sommes unis prêts à souligner
les efforts de ceux qui sont en
responsabilité et qui agissent prêt à
écouter ceux qui font des propositions
utiles notamment au Parlement pour
améliorer l'efficacité de nos
dispositifs de lutte
merci
dans la suite du débat la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Claude requier pour le
groupe
RDSE monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers
collègues bien que n'appartenant pas à
la commission d'enquête sur le rôle des
banques et des acteurs financiers dans
l'évasion fiscale et en l'absence de mon
excellent collègue et ami le sénateur
Yvon Collin je m'exprime au nom de ce
mon groupe sur ce sujet de première
importance d'ailleurs j'ai cru
comprendre que l'actualité
politico-judiciaire avait pu parfois
rattraper les travaux de la commission
d'enquête qui ont pu connaître une
atmosphère relativement tendue inutile
de revenir sur les révélations de ces
derniers mois qui ont bouleversé
certaines incertitudes quant au
caractère inébranable du secret bancaire
et de l'opacité des centres offshore par
lesquels transite la fraude et l'évasion
fiscale pour autant l'essentiel des
conclusions de cette commission
d'enquête sénatoriale tout comme celle
de la précédente commission sur
l'évasion des capitaux et des actifs
hors- de France de de 2012 ne reste pas
moins très intéressante et mérite toute
attention de législateur ces travaux ont
débuté quelques mois seulement à les
révélations du dossier offshore leak
depuis les dirigeants des plus grandes
puissances se mobilisent pour mettre en
œuvre l'échange automatique
d'information considéré désormais comme
la solution bien la solution pour lutter
contre ces fléau à la suite des
États-Unis qui ont voté en 2010 la loi
fatka obligeant l'ensemble des
établissements financiers du monde à
fournir les informations qu'il
détiennent sur les comptes et les flux
financiers bénéficiant directement ou
indirectement contribu américain les
déclarations prenant l'échange
automatique d'information se sont
multipliées le 9 avril 2013 le ministre
français de l'économie et des finances
adresse avec ses homologues britanniques
allemands espagnol et italiens un
courrier à la Commission européenne
demandant l'instauration d'un fatka
Européen fin avril 2013 les ministres
des Finances du G20 réunis à Washington
exhorte la communauté internationale à
adopter l'échange automatique
d'information le 12 juin la Commission
européenne publie une proposition
tendant à étendre l'échange automatique
d'informations entre les administrations
fiscales de l'Union européenne le 18
juin David Cameron qui réunit ses
homologues du G8 en Irlande du Nord fait
monte d'une grande détermination pour
lutter contre l'optimisation fiscale et
contre les paradis fiscaux y compris y
compris dans les territoires attachés à
la Couronne britannique en outre
l'ensemble des dirigeants présents à ce
sommet Appell à faire de l'échange
automatique d'information le nouveau
stand standard mondial le 20 juillet
lors de la réunion des ministres des
Finances du G20 à Saint-Pétersbourg
l'OCDE présente son plan d'action pour
lutter contre l'érosion de la base
d'imposition et le transfert des
bénéfices le BEPS le 26 juillet la
France promulue sa loi de séparation et
de régularisation des activités
bancaires qui comportte certaines
dispositions visant à lutter contre les
paradis fiscaux en septembre le
Parlement suisse entérine l'accord avec
les États-Unis relatif à la mise en
place de fatka enfin le 7 novembre le
Parlement adopté définitivement le
projet de loi relatif à la lutte contre
la fore fiscale et la grande délinquance
économique et financière ce projet de
loi dont certaines dispositions viennent
d'être censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel comporte à un point dter
les avancés qui permettront de palier
certaines carences mises en évidence par
le rapport de la commission d'enquête
ainsi la définition d'un délit de fraude
fiscale aggravé commis en bande organisé
permet perettra de mieux sanctionner les
intermédiaires qui échappent aujourd'hui
à toute condamnation sans qui la frude
fiscale serait sans doute la plart
plupart du cas des cas impossibles à
l'échelle internationale l'OCDE est en
train d'élaborer son modèle de
convention standardisé qui pour
l'échange automatique d'information
qu'elle devrait présenter dans le cadre
de la prochaine réunion des ministres
des Finances du G20 qui se tiendra à
brisban en Australie en septembre
2014 si les changes automatiques s
aujourd'hui s'imposé c'est bien que les
solutions précédemment mises en œuvre
ont échoué ainsi les différentes listes
de paradis fiscaux ne se sont sont pas
révélés très efficaces et sont
aujourd'hui presque vides quant aux
conventions bilatérale d'échange
d'information sur demande si le nombre a
explosé depuis quelques années on voit
bien que la coopération effective est
loin d'être une réalité avec tous les
états de même les évaluations réalisées
dans le cadre de la revue par les paires
ne semblent pas suivi des faits
l'échange automatique devrait donc
permettre de lever un certain nombre
d'obstacles qui ont permis jusqu'à
présent à la concurrence fiscale
dommageable de perdurer voire de
prospérer il faut donc se féliciter des
prémisses de sa mise en œuvre au niveau
mondial toutefois permettez-moi de ne
pas être aussi enthousiaste que d'autres
car il me semble que que si l'échange
automatique d'information constitue une
avancé indéable il ne résout pas un
certain nombre de difficultés qu'il
faudra nécessairement lev pour lutter
efficacement contre la fraude et
l'optimisation fiscale ces difficultés
sont présentes à deux niveaux en amont
tout d'abord les faiblesses du système
juridique institutionnel et fiscal de
certains territoires conduisent tout
simplement à l'absence d'information
échangeable ou à des informations très
lacunaires pour ces juridictions
totalement opaques l'échange automatique
d'information ne changera rien quelle
solution la communauté internationale
enésage t-elle pour ce typ ce type de
situation en aval ensuite se pose la
question du traitement et de
l'exploitation des informations
recueillies ainsi les moyens financiers
humains des administrations en charge de
la lutte contre la fraude et le
blanchiment qui sont déjà très largement
insuffisants comme a souligné le rapport
à la commission d'enquête devont donc
être significativement renforcés je
citerai à titre d'exemple une phrase du
rapport qui concerne Tracfin la cellule
don de lutte contre le blanchimement je
cite les efforts de productivité demandé
à tracf ne sont pas réalistes avec 90
fonctionnaires pour traiter 30000
informations par an le déséquilibre est
P temp or avec l'échange automatique
d'information à l'échelle mondiale ce
type d'équilibre ne sera plus que
prignant en autre au-delà des moyens
face à une une innovation financière
toujours plus complexe les compétences
techniques de ce charger de la
surveiller doit être adapté comme le
souligné le rapport je cite le contrôle
fiscal ainsi que superviseurs financiers
pourrait sans doute réaliser des graines
de productivité par une meilleure
coordination de leurs actions ou encore
par le développement du capital humain
qui appelle une formation permanente dès
lors les propositions du rapport de la
commission d'enquête qui vise à allouer
des moyens suffisants à la lutte contre
la fraude l'évasion fiscale et le
blanchiment et à renforcer les effectifs
et l'éventail des compét de certaines
entités spécialisées sont plus que
jamais d'actualité le chemin à parcourir
pour lut efficacement contre la fraude
et l'évason fiscale reste donc long
autant au point national
qu'international c'est pourquoi s'il
faut soutenir sans hésitation l'échange
automatique d'information il ne faut pas
le considérer comme une solution
miraculeuse et universelle car le
meilleur remède reste sans conteste la
dissuasion grâce à une politique
exemplaire et systématique d'une grande
fermeté à l'égard des
fraudeurs
dans la suite du débat la parole est à
Monsieur Louis du Vernois pour le groupe
UMP
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues dans le cadre de mes
nombreuses missions à
l'étranger à la rencontre des
communautés françaises
expatriées j'observe dans certains pays
la réalité de l'évasion
fiscale je précise d'emblé que
malheureusement un amalgame est très
souvent fait entre évadés fiscaux et
expatrié dont le départ est justifié par
l'exercice ou la recherche d'un emploi à
l'étranger je peux d'ailleurs témoigner
que tous ne roul pas sur l'or loin s'en
faut l'évasion fiscale est une
expression assez
stigmatisante qui ne reflète qu'une
partie de la
réalité il existe certes des gens céd
dans de très gros patrimoine et qui
choisissent de
s'installer dans un paradis fiscale si
cette attitude est condamnable elle peut
toutefois se comprendre en raison du
matraquage fiscal qui existe en France
aujourd'hui l'actualité le démontre tous
les jours pour
autant l'érosion de la base fiscale et
les témoignages entre autres d'avocat
fiscalistes nous donnent à penser que
cet exil fiscal s'est accéléré au cours
des dernières années à ce sujet je tiens
à saluer la punugiaacité de notre
président de la commission des finances
Philippe
Marini qui par son insistance est
parvenu à obtenir des
chiffres de la direction général des
finances
publiques très instructif et
sur les départs à l'étranger de gros
contribuables ces
données ne portent
ou ne couvre plutôt que la période
allant jusqu'en
2011 celle de 2012 ne pourront être
connu qu'au deè semestre de
2014 la dynamique est cependant
lancé espérons que cette communication
établie entre l'administration et le
Parlement perdurera et permettra de
mesurer avec plus de précision cette
tendance qui impacte fortement nos
recettes
publiques l'Assemblée des Français de
l'Étranger présidée de droit par le
ministre des Affaires étrangères a en
effet constaté qu'il était le plus
souvent impossible de connaître le
montant des prélèvements sociaux sur les
revenus immobiliers et les plusvalues
imobiliire de sources françaises pour
les non résidents fiscaux de même que la
répartition entre non résidents fiscaux
quel que soit leur origine pour mémoire
les revenus de location d'immeuble et
les plusvalues immobilières des
nonrésidents sont désormais soumis au
prélèvements sociaux en plus des droits
d'enregistrement le Sénat quant à lui
s'intéresse depuis longtemps à l'évasion
des capitaux le débat d'aujourd'hui
s'inscrit donc dans la Contin
de celui que nous avions tenu en octobre
2012 et auquel j'ai eu grand intérêt à
participer à la suite de la publication
du rapport de la commission d'enquête
sur l'évasion des capitaux et des actifs
hors de France et ses incidences
fiscales ce rapport avait été le fruit
d'un long travail collectif de près de 6
mois rassemblant des sénateurs de toute
tendance politique le débat
d'aujourd'hui inscrit donc dans la
continuité de cette réflexion suite à la
publication d'un nouveau rapport de la
commission d'enquête sur le rôle des
banques et acteur financiers dans
l'évasion fiscale permettant cette
fois-ci une analyse sous un angle
différent cette analyse de la complexité
des circuits bancaires et de l'opacité
des pratiques financières permettra de
mieux cerner les limites légales de
l'optim l'optimisation fiscale autrement
dit la question qui se pose et à
laquelle ces rapports parlementaire
tente de répondre y a-t-il une
incitation à la
fraude les grandes banques ont en effet
toutes des filiales dans les paradis
fiscaux quel est par ailleurs le rôle
des multiples
intervenants avocats fiscaliste
assureurs conseiller société financière
et cetera le shadow banking par exemple
et comme on l'appelle est un système
parallèle qui regroupe des acteurs
exempés des disciplines s'appliquant aux
banques il peut s'agir
pmel de sociétés financières de
véhicules de
titrisation de fonds monétaires de
courtiers en valeur mobilière de hedge
funds et certainement de bien d'autres
choses encore
ce système représenterait près de la
moitié du secteur bancaire régulé soit
trillions de dollars en
2011 c'est un chiffre
colossal nous devons pouvoir y faire
face néanmoins la lutte contre la fraude
fiscale doit faire
l'objet d'un travail en profondeur
transpartisan à l'image de celui du
Sénat et sans aucune volonté de
récupération
politique le groupe UMP n'a ainsi pas
approuvé la réaction à chaud du
gouvernement au lendemain de l'affaire
Cahusac et des dégâts qu'elle avait
qu'elle a occasionné dans
l'opinion le groupe UMP a souhaité
dénoncer cette attitude afin de limiter
l'OND de choc et le discrédit jeté sur
la classe
politique la censure hier par le Conseil
constitutionnel
de plusieurs articles de la Loi sur la
fraude fiscale en est l'illustration la
plus flagrante monsieur le
ministre le rapport de la commission
d'enquête est pour sa part le fruit d'un
travail plus réfléchi qui a abouti à un
certain nombre de propositions
auxquelles je souscris naturellement
très
largement je partage l'idée d'améliorer
la prévention par un renforcement de la
transparence mais mais aussi et surtout
par une harmonisation
fiscale absolument nécessaire au niveau
européen mais aussi il convient
également de renforcer la répression à
l'Assemblée des Français de l'Étranger
nous avons depuis longtemps reconnu la
nécessité d'adopter certaines mesures
j'en citerai
quelquesunes renforcement de la
coopération et de l'harmonisation
fiscale en particulier en Europe
meilleure surveillance F des opérations
de cession acquisition et
fusion approche pragmatique du spectre
très large de la problématique des prix
de transfert à travers l'exemple des
propositions allant dans le sens indiqué
le rapport de la commission d'enquête
adoptée à l'unanimité faut-il le
rappeler souligne une fois encore la
qualité du travail sénatorial je
souhaiterais dans les circonstances
remercier le président de la Commission
d'enquête François Pillet ainsi que leur
rapporteur Éric boet qui dans la
diversité de leurs opinions ont su
travailler dans un climat constructif et
aboutir à un rapport objectif dont je
l'espère ardemment les propositions
pourront faire œuvre utile je vous
remercie dans la suite du débat la
parole est à madame Cécile kman pour le
groupe
CRC s vous
pr un
plus c'est comme chez
moi monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues notre
groupe a été particulièrement inspiré à
demandé la création de cette seconde
commission d'enquête sur la fraude et
l'évasion fiscale et en l'espèce sur
l'utilisation des services des
établissements bancaires quant au
développement de ses comportements
illégaux ou aux franges de l'illégalité
il importait à notre sens de donner à
penser et à réfléchir aux parlementaires
aux militants politiques syndicaux
associatifs et de manière plus générale
aux citoyens sur ces questions qui ont
particulièrement occupé l'espace du
débat depuis 2008 notre collègue Éric
Boquet avec le président de la
Commission à Monsieur Pillet Éric qu
deux fois rapporteur de ces commissions
d'enquête rencontre d'ailleurs à chaque
fois que l'occasion lui en est offerte
une attention à un intérêt particulier
pour l'ensemble des questions soulevées
qu'il s'agisse bien évidemment de la
structure et de la consistance de la
fraude et de l'évasion fiscale mais
aussi des acteurs des auteurs des
processus rouages et circuits qui
l'organisent la légitime parfois le
monde de la finance n'a peut-être pas
qu'un seul visage pour reprendre une
expression utilisée il y a moins de 2
ans
avec le travail accompli par les deux
commissions d'enquête du Sénat il
commence à être un peu mieux connu qu'il
ne l'était jusqu'ici la chose n'est pas
sans intérêt sans jeu de mots au moment
où nous sommes confrontés au double défi
de la réforme fiscale nécessaire et du
redressement de notre pays de son
économie à la reconstruction de la
société de lien humain fraternel et
ouvert qui rendent possible le vivre
ensemble ce qui ressort du rapport de
cette seconde commission d'enquête c'est
bel et bien que nos état éablissement de
crédit ne joue pas tout à fait le rôle
que l'on serait en droit d'attendre eux
de pardon surtout dans le contexte
économique et social que nous traversons
pour nous les établissements de crédit
ont une fonction principale dans le
respect des conditions et critères de
solvabilité et de prudence requis ils
doivent faire en sorte que l'argent
disponible déposé par les particuliers
les entreprises les collectivités
locales soit affecté dans le soutien à
l'activité économique là est le point
nodal de l'intervention bancaire dans
notre pays
élu d'un département de forte tradition
industrielle mais lourdement frappé dans
les dernières décennies par les plans
sociaux les fermeture ou réduction
d'activités département qui compte
aujourd'hui plus de 37000 personnes
privées d'emploi de catégoria a près de
58000 toutes catégories confondu dont
plus de 10000 ne perçoivent plus
désormais que le RSA je connais la
difficulté qui que rencontre de
nombreuses entreprises TPE PME à accéder
au crédit bancairire qu'il s'agisse de
disposer d'une ligne de trésorerie pour
faire face notamment à leur obligations
légal social et fiscal ou de crédit leur
permettant d'investir dans de nouveaux
matériel nouveaux processus de
production projets susceptibles de
générer des emplois nouveaux sur les
territoires la question est donc posée
peu ou prou les Nigériens laissent en
effet passer sur leur compte bancaire 10
milliards d'euros de revenus par an les
données sont d'ailleurs corroborées par
la Banque de France qui indique que sous
une forme ou sous une autre compte à vu
compte sur livivr et cetera 16,9
milliards d'euros sont disponibles dans
les établissements de crédit du
département de la Loire pour financer
l'activité
économique nous avons à la même date
16,4 milliards d'euros de crédit
accordés à l'économie dont 9,9 milliards
sont par nature des crédits de long
terme puisqu'il s'agit de prêmobilier
qu'on qu'on ne s'y trompe pas cette
situation n'a rien d'exceptionnel elle
est la marque d'un pays où l'on ne fait
pas confiance aux entreprises quand
elles veulent se développer créer de la
créer de la richesse et des emplois en
septembre 2013 et malgré la mise en
place de la BPI malgré la séparation des
activités bancaires nous restons donc
dans un climat de faible mobilisation
des sommes disponibles pour le
développement de l'activité économique
ainsi et à l'échelle nationale sur notre
million de PME nous avons plus de 50
milliards d'euros de ressources de
crédit inemployé et il en est de même
pour nos 5000 entreprises de taille
intermédiaire pour aller plus en détail
si le secteur de l'habitat et de
l'immobilier bénéficie toujours d'un
certain soutien financier il brasse près
de 328 milliards d'euros dans Cours ce
sont là encore souvent des empreunts de
long terme les secteur de l'industrie
manufacturière sont en délicatesse avec
les banques puisque fin septembre les
activités industrielles réalisaient 94,2
milliards d'euros de crédit mais pour
une enveloppe disponible de
184,8 milliards d'euros soit un taux de
mobilisation des capacités de 51 % nous
sommes alors très éloignés de la règle
commune qui monte une Mobil isation de
77 % des capacités de crédit il est donc
temps à notre avis que les banques dans
leur activité de siège comme dans leurs
activités de détail change de pratique
et de priorités la collecte de l'épne de
l'épargne salariale a vu la captation de
la trésorerie des entreprises la
distribution de produits d'épargne
défiscalisés ne peuvent continuer de
conduire à une situation où les
potentiels de croissance de création
d'emplois de réponse aux besoins
collectifs sont voire anéanti par
des choix de gestion bancaire
privilégiant les activités pour compte
propre les opérations les plus juteuses
et les plus rentables sur le court terme
sans compter les opérations
d'optimisation menées de longues mains à
partir des établissements de détail vers
les filiales implantées dans des paradis
fiscaux la situation du secteur bancaire
dans notre dans notre pays suffit à
notre avis à montrer que les difficultés
de notre économie ne résident pas dans
un terme très à la mode et très
médiatique dit du coût du travail pour
reprendre cette détestable expression un
coût de travail qui serait trop élevé un
système de prélèvement fiscaux et
sociaux pesant et incompréhensible une
absence d'innovation de recherche de
développement mais au contraire nous
pensons que les difficultés résident bel
et bien dans une dichotomie dramatique
entre capacité de financement et besoin
de financement il est anormal mes chers
collègues que dans un pays disposant de
quelques-unes des plus grandes banques
européenne et mondiale riche d'une
expertise et de compétences dans un
contexte où le tau directeur de la
Banque centrale européenne grande caisse
de refinancement de tous les acteurs du
secteur financier donc ce pays n'a
jamais été aussi faible nous n'ayons
toujours pas les moyens d'envisager plus
que 9 diè de points de la croissance du
PIB en 2014 sans même être d'ailleurs
certain que cette croissance sera
écologiquement responsable et acceptable
il est donc grand temps à peu de jours
de l'examen d'un collè collectif
budgétaire où la dette de l'État va
solder définitivement le coût du
désastre du Crédit Lyonnais que la
puissance publique soit à l'initiative
d'une nouvelle définition et orientation
de notre secteur bancaire et pour
reprendre l'image de notre collègue
Corine bouchou c'est certainement là la
saison 3 de cette série engagée il y a
maintenant un peu plus de 2 ans et
Monsieur le Ministre même si bien
évidemment nous nous félicitons comme
toujours de votre présence ici parmi
nous nous regrettons que vous n'ayez pu
être accompagné ce matin d'un des
ministres en charge des différentes
questions en lien avec le secteur
économique et bancaire la libéralisation
et la maîtrise privée du secteur
bancaire n'ont pas apporté à l'économie
française ce qui a été alors annoncé les
collectivités locales ont d'ailleurs
payé pour le savoir avec la faillite de
Dexia qui a distribué ces dernières
années des emprunts toxiques pour
lesquels aucune solution admissible n'a
de notre point de vue encore été trouvée
le est à la fixation des règles plus
strictes d'allocation d'une part des
ressources des banques cela peut
commencer avec l'épargne des fiscalisés
et à envisager en tant que que de besoin
pardon la maîtrise publique des
établissements dont les pratiques ne
seraient pas conformes aux nécessités du
temps vous pouvez donc compter sur nous
bien évidemment monsieur le ministre
pour être à l'initiative de nombreuses
propositions et travailler à vos côtés
pour que des réponses concrètes puissent
être apportées parce que je l'ai
démontré c'est à la fois un enjeu pour
notre économie et donc pour nos
concitoyennes et nos concitoyens et je
tiens encore ici bien évidemment à à
féliciter le travail de l'ensemble des
membres de la commission notre
rapporteur Éric bequet pardon et son
Président je vous
remercie dans la suite du débat la
parole est maintenant à Monsieur Michel
bon pour le groupe
socialiste
monsieur le Président je
salue monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
commission d'enquête monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues
ce
rapport s'inscrit dans la
continuité d'une réflexion engagée par
le Sénat et ce rapport constitue donc la
suite des travaux d'une précédente
commission
d'enquête la somme d'information et la
pertinence des propositions du précédent
rapport sont sont aujourd'hui pleinement
confirmé et je dirais même pleinement
conforté conforté par le contexte de
l'explosion d'affaires de
scandal ces affaires ces scandales
touchant tout autant des individus que
des
institutions de forte notoriété
elles sont
largement équé dans le rapport
elle concerne tout
autant à la fois la fuite des capitaux
des particuliers l'évaporation fiscale
des entreprises et les trafics de
milieux criminel
organisé dans un contexte de crise et
d'effort
budgétaire ces affaires ces scandales
ont heurté avec raison nos concitoyens
et alimenter hélas la défiance à
l'égard du système financier
international mais aussi à l'égard des
responsables
politiques il nous faut donc
impérativement comme le dit le
rapport mieux connaître par l'expertise
et par l'analyse les défaillances du
système bancaire et des acteurs financés
il nous faut impérativement mieux
connaître leur rôle dans l'évasion des
capitaux pour mieux
comprendre je reprends ainsi le titre du
rapport mieux comprendre pour mieux
compattre c'est pour cela que je me
réjouis à mon tour du travail accompli
par notre commission d'enquête et je
soutiens bien sûr pleinement les
propositions concrètes précises parfois
techniques qui permettent de doter si
elles sont suivies des faits notre
démocratie des armes nécessaires pour
combattre la fraude et le crime
fiscal ce que la crise de 2008 a révélé
au grand jour notamment avec la faillite
de lesans Brothers c'est le risque qu'il
y avait à considéré comme
acquis le principe du tobic to file qui
prévalait alors dans le domaine des
institutions financières la surprise de
cette faillite a levé le voile sur le
manque de visibilité de la situation
réelle des banques et des faiblesses du
système financier international le
constat dressé dans le rapport est à cet
égard très éclairant sur le rôle des
places offshore sur les pratiques
édifiantes des banques et sur le rôle de
certains pays dans les stratégies
d'évasion fiscale qui constituent un
risque évident un risque important de
déstabilisation des économies est-il
besoin de rappeler la crise chipriote du
printemps dernier les actifs des banques
locales représentaient 750 % du PIB de
ce pays
qui dénombrait 1400 demandes
d'enregistrement de sociétés russes pour
le seul mois de janvier
2012 l'implosion du secteur bancaire sur
lequel était fondé le modèle de
renaissance économique de ce pays fut
largement dû à la recherche d'une
situation de rente grâce à une fiscalité
exagérément avantageuse pour le secteur
financier et une ouverture excessive aux
sociétés ch sur ce point
la disproportion
entre la taille de l'économie d'un pays
le volume des actifs financiers est
éloquente comment expliquer que les îles
Caiman ou le Luxembourg soient des pays
destinataire d'investissements
transnationaux à hauteur de 2000
milliards d'euros chacun pour 2011 quand
le Brésil et la Chine réunis pèsent pour
moins de la moitié
parallèlement cela a été fréquemment
rappelé au cours des auditions l'opacité
de l'organisation des banques ne permet
pas un travail efficace des organismes
de contrôle le déploiement des filiales
est aujourd'hui tel qu'il est impossible
de déterminer le périmètre de chaque
établissement face à cette situation un
certain nombre d'initiatives ont été
prises en France depuis 2 ans elles vont
dans le sens d'une meilleure visibilité
et d'un meilleur contrôle des activités
des banques je veux rappeler ici la loi
bancaire que notre Assemblée a enrichi
en prenant en compte les premiers
travaux de notre commission d'enquête
par exemple la séparation des activités
bancaires qui va dans le sens d'une
limitation des risques pour les
particuliers et un meilleur encadrement
des filiales ou bien l'obligation faite
aux banques de publier des informations
précises sur leur activité filiale par
filiale pays par pays comme le préconise
la proposition 21 de notre commission
d'enquête je veux également rappeler la
loi contre la fraude et la grande
délinquence financière qui a renforcé
les sanctions en cas de défaut de
réponse ou de réponse partielle à une
mise en demeure de produit de produire
certains éléments déclaratifs relatif
aux actionnaires aux filiales et aux
participations et qui a étendu le champ
de compétence de la brigade nationale de
répression de la dévinquance fiscale on
peut aussi se féliciter enfin que dans
le projet de loi de finances 2014
l'Assemblée nationale à l'initiative de
son groupe socialiste a adopté des
dispositions rendant obligatoire la
déclaration schémas d'optimisation
fiscale en écho à la proposition 22 de
notre commission
d'enquête l'environnement relatif à la
lutte contre l'évasion des capitaux est
donc en profonde évolution en France
mais il reste d'importants chantiers à
mener plusieurs auditions ont mis en
avant le fait que notre système demeure
défaillant lorsqu'il relève de décisions
individuelles et cela va dans les deux
sens c'est-à-dire pour le lanceur
d'alerte et pour l'employé qui constate
des
irrégularités dans ce cas quelles sont
les protections dont il bénéficie le cas
médiatique de Monsieur falsani dans
l'affaire HSBC et le changement de
position de la France à son sujet en est
un exemple éclairant de
même pour ceux qui manient le risque
dans une recherche de profit des
obligations dev
fortement les responsabiliser
individuellement c'est donc une
véritable révolution culturelle qu'il
faut impulsé par la recherche d'une
meilleure connaissance des
multinationales financières une
meilleure connaissance de leur Bénéfic
réels et une meilleure organisation du
contrôle et de la supervision des
institutions bancaires cette évolution
culturelle passe d'abord par une une
pleine transparence des comptes
bancaires par des dispositifs d'échange
automatique d'information entre banque
et administration fiscale cette
véritable force de frappe a permis aux
États-Unis d'obtenir ces derniers mois
des résultats impensables il y a
seulement 5 ans c'est un objectif que
nous devons nous aussi partager avec nos
partenaires européens dans les mois qui
viennent il en va de notre crédibilité
comme de notre efficacité dans ce combat
contre la fraude et l'évasion fiscale
dont le coût pour les finances publiques
est énorme 2000 € par an et par habitant
dans l'espace européens et 60 milliards
d'euros en France chaque année soit une
fois et demi le budget de l'Éducation
nationale pour conclure je voudrais
monsieur le ministre
attirer votre attention sur deux
questions tout
d'abord sur la dernière proposition
formulé dans notre rapport relatif à ce
que l'on appelle le verrou de
ber cela fait des années que nous avons
ce débat sur la nécessaire collaboration
ou l'absence de collaboration entre
l'administration fiscale et le juge
pénal en la matière il me semble
hautement
souhaitable de renforcer les moyens de
l'administration fiscale dans la lutte
contre le crime fiscal et parallèlement
parallèlement de permettre au magistrats
d'enquêter et de poursuivre beaucoup
plus librement les délinquants lorsqu'il
s'agit de fraude fiscale que l'on
qualifie de complexe et pas seulement
lorsqu'il s'agit de blanchiment fiscal
ensuite et ce sera ma deuxième réflexion
monsieur le ministre je voudrais
souligner que l'échelon européen est
assurément le niveau d'intervention
pertinent pour mener une lutte efficace
contre l'évasion des ressources fiscales
à ce titre on peut se féliciter du rôle
renforcé de supervision et de contrôle
maintenant dévolu à la BCE mais il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin
notamment vers une harmonisation fiscale
européenne et vers
l'instauration de la taxe des
transactions financières après l'échec
d'une initiative européenne la France
doit jouer un rôle moteur elle ne
peut-être à mon
sens être un frein et avoir une attitude
frileuse qui se traduirait par un recul
de la nécessaire coopération
renforcé en la matière mes chers
collègues je veux à mon tour et ce sera
mon dernier mot saluer le président le
rapporteur et les membres de notre
commission d'enquête pour la qualité de
leur
travail un travail qui prend
aujourd'hui une dimension nouvelle avec
la récente décision du gouvernement
d'ouvrir un très grand débat sur notre
fiscalité ce rappord d'inform
est en quelque sorte la première
contribution du Sénat à ce grand débat
national et nous pouvons nous en
féliciter mes chers collègues je vous
remercie de votre
attention dans la suite du débat la
parole est maintenant à Monsieur jean-
Yv Lecomte pour le groupe
socialiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues tout
d'abord j'aimerais saluer le travail le
sérieux et la le travail sérieux de la
Commission et la diversité des auditions
et l'intérêt des auditions que nous
avons pu mener durant tous ces mois nous
avons été souvent saisis de vertigge à
l'occasion des témoignages que nous
avons pu entendre le tpai de certains
opérateurs qui n'hésitent pas à faire
des roadshow en France proposant des
montages d'évasion fiscale à des riches
particuliers ou à des entreprises mais
aussi au au moyens à la multiplication
des moyens de se soustraire aux règles
nationales que donnent à la fois les
nouvelles technologies conjuguées à une
ingéniosité financière de plus en plus
élaboré en réalité ce qu'on constate
c'est que avec ces nouvelles
technologies et Internet ce que Salvador
aliand dénoncé à la tribune de l'ONU à
72 en 1972 est encore plus d'actualité
lorsqu'il disait nous faisons face à un
conflit frontal entre les entreprises
transnationales et les états ceux-ci
sont courtcircuités dans leurs décision
fondamentales politique économique et
militaire par des organisations globales
qui ne dépendent d'aucun état et dont
les activités ne sont contrôlées par
aucun Parlement ni aucune institution
représentative de l'intérêt collectif
cette remarque elle est encore
d'actualité toujours plus d'actualité et
les nouvelles technologies de
l'information
renforce la le le le le sujet de de
celle-ci alors l'évasion fiscale bien
entendu est un sujet d'actualité vous
l'avez tous signalé avant moi mais mes
chers collègues contte tenu de d'abord
de la la crise financière de de
2008 des institutions financières
défaillantes qui ont fait appel à la
puissance publique pour pouvoir être
sauvé un soutien qui obère aujourd'hui
dans beaucoup de d'État les capacités de
ces mêmes états de la puissance publique
à développer des politiques publiques et
qui a contraint ces États à mener
aujourd'hui des politiques de rigueur
budgétaire sinon d'austérité et dans
cette dans ces conditions ce soutien à
des institutions financières est
particulièrement mal ressenti et quand
on ajoute que ce que la puissance
publique à dû aider sont souvent les
institutions financières les moins
vertueuses cela renforce le sentiment de
de révolte et d'injustice face à cette
situation et c'est la raison pour
laquelle dans ce contexte ceux qui se
soustrait ceux qui se soustrait à
l'impôt sont de moins en moins tolérés
et doivent être poursuivis on constate
que depuis de nombreuses années une
mission d'enquête sur les agences de
notation avait en particulier souligner
le décalage exponentiel que nous avions
d'une part entre les engagements
financiers de l'ensemble des
établissements financiers et d'autre
part la situation de l'économie réelle
ce décalage il est en partie dû à la
croissance des produits dérivés au
trading à haute fréquence aux
algorithmes de plus en plus sophistiqués
de temps en temps ça peut répondre à des
besoins d'ailleurs l'assurance il fait
les les les les sociétés d'assurance ils
font souvent appel parce que ça permet
de limiter un risque donné mais
globalement nous avons des
établissements financiers qui ont des
engagements qui sont de plus en plus en
total décalage et en croissance absolue
par rapport à l'économie réelle et ça
engendre une situation où les moyens
financiers de la puissance publique
dépend sont proportionnelles à à
l'économie réelle tandis que les moyens
des établissements financiers sont
proportionnels à leurs engagements d'où
une difficulté pour avoir les moyens de
les surveiller de les réguler et de
s'assurer que des situations comme en
2008 ne seront pas récurrentes bien
entendu face à cette
situation la coopération à la fois
multilatérale et européenne est la
solution principale mais pour cela il
faut l'aborder de manière complète et
franche ne pas accepter par exemple en
terme de paradis fiscaux ce qui a pu
être fait en 2008 que si il signent
entre eux des accords de reconnaissance
alors progressivement ils sortent des
listes les plus
noires ne pas faire d'hypocrisie
plusieurs de
nos intervenants ont souligné que même
des États qui se déclaraient vertueux
avaient finalement le dans leur
arrière-cours un paradis fiscal qui leur
permettait de faire certaines opérations
non avoables si on veut aller dans cette
lutte contre les paradis fiscaux ça doit
être contre avec sans hypocrisie et en
sachant qu'effectivement un certain
nombre d'opérations non avoables ne
pourront plus être faite et ne pas
signer de convention fiscale à caractère
commercial je pense ici à ce qui a pu
être fait avec le Panama ou avec le
Qatar vous connaissez madame Goulet mes
préoccupations sur ce sujet mais quand
on signe un accord de coopération
fiscale on ne peut pas le signer
simplement parce qu'il y a un marché à
la clé parce que c'est ce genre de chose
qui pollue l'ensemble de la démarche que
nous pouvons avoir après parce que si
nous le faisons nous légitimons pour les
autres et c'est tout le système qui
tombe et ce n'est pas acceptable d'autre
part dans l'Union européenne dans
l'Union européenne nous avons 28 pays 28
pays quelques-uns dont on sait
parfaitement que le secret bancaire
reste parmi leurs
principes ça doit être dénoncé comme un
cancer même si ça doit être
progressivement levé nous comprenons
l'Union au début n'avait pas cette
exigence maintenant elle devient
indispensable parce que il y a une
coopération budgétaire il y a des
solidarités il y a une zone euro en
commun une solidarité de budgetaire de
plus en plus nette et nous ne pouvons
plus accepter ce qui était peut-être
acceptable au début que que le
Luxembourg ou l'Autriche ou la Suisse
qui n'est pas dans l'Union européenne
mais qui est associé par beaucoup de
traités bilatéraux ce genre de chose ne
peut plus marcher si nous construisons
une zone de solidarité en Europe
j'insiste aussi sur le fait que 28
membres dans l'Union
européenne ça fait
756 théoriquement convention fiscale
bilatérale entre les pays membres de
l'Union européenne comment voulez-vous
qu'avec une telle diversité de
conventions fiscales même si beaucoup se
ressemblent on puisse s retrouver
n'est-il pas temps de faire une
convergence fiscale dans l'Union
européenne sans cette convergence
fiscale tous nos discours seront des
paroles et pas des actes il est
important d'aller dans cette direction
et je suis particulièrement satisfait
que ça ça fasse partie des orientations
de la réorientation de l'Europe que le
Président de la République a mis en
œuvre depuis son élection et qui seront
j'en suis sûr au cœur des élections
européenne de l'année prochaine
j'ajouteraiis que pour commenter
quelques points du du rapport la
proposition numéro 17 que introduite par
Madame Nathalie Goulet sur les cartes
non nominatives c'est une préoccupation
que je partage parce qu'effectivement
non seulement elles permettent de
l'évasion fiscale mais en plus ce que
j'ai pu constater c'est qu'il n'y a
aucun moyen sérieux de surveiller et de
contrôler sérieusement la manière dont
ces organismes qui en France aussi V ce
type de carte effectivement ne participe
pas à l'évasion fiscale concernant
les les prérogatives une autre
proposition son particulièrement
intéressante C concernant les les
prérogatives des institutions
représentatifes du personnel dans les
établissements financiers ça me semble
important que le personnel soit protégé
et capable de dénoncer les agissements
contraire à l'intérêt collectif qui
puisse être fait enfin la lutte contre
les conflits d'intérêts pas
d'aller-retour public privé bien entendu
les la compétence des uns peut-être
utile à l'autre un transfert d'un à
l'autre peut de temps en temps se
comprendre sous certaines règles mais
pas d'allerretour systématique enfin en
conclusion je dirais que euh l'évasion
sera plus difficile s'il y a plus
d'harmonisation depuis 1 an nous avons
fortement
renforcé notre arsenal répressif mais
c'est j'allais dire
de la réparation ce n'est pas une action
active l'action active c'est s'engager
sur la voie de l'harmonisation fiscale
entre nos partenaires dans le débat et
vous l'avez vous l'avez signalé monsieur
bererson sur la remise à plat de notre
système il est important qu'il y ait de
la lésibilité dans l'impôt on a beaucoup
parlé dans cet échange des échanges
automatiques d'information mais je vous
dis et nous avons déjà des exemples si
ces échanges automatique d'information
ne sont pas exploitable parce que d'un
pays à l'autre nous ne savons pas de
quel impôt nous parlons ils ne serviront
à rien pire ils seront décrédibilisés et
j'ai déjà des exemples d'information
envoyé par le ministère des Finances à
des à d'autres pays qui ont été
contreproductifs parce qu'ils ont été
mal mal envoyés et mal compris l'échange
automatique d'information bien entendu
est indispensable mais sans lisibilité
de l'impôt du autre et de celui de nos
partenaires ça ne sert à rien lisibilité
de l'impôt indispensable efficacité bien
sûr si don la puissance publique n'a pas
les moyens d'agir enfin stabilité pour
que les opérateurs économiques que nous
souhaitons inviter sur notre territoire
puisse être confiant dans l'avenir de
nos de notre pays les entreprises elles
ont besoin de sécurité juridique elles
ont besoin de marcher et elles ont
besoin de faire confi d'inspirer
confiance à la fois leurs clients à
leurs fournisseurs et à leurs
investisseurs ce sont des
caractéristiques que les paradis fiscaux
ne peuvent pas leur offrir ce sont
peut-être des paradis fiscaux ce ne sont
pas des paradis du droit et d'ailleurs
nous devons nous attacher à faire qu'il
n'en soit jamais justement pour que il
ne présente aucun intérêt aux
entreprises et en conclusion je vous
diraiis harmonisation harmonisation
harmonisation mais faisons attention à
une chose dans notre volonté de lutter
contre l'évasion fiscale ne tuons pas
ceux qui veulent agir en France et en
matière de prix de transfert il y a un
curseur j'ai déjà remarqué au cours des
dernières années qu'un certain nombre
d'entreprises avaient préféré aller
ailleurs cont tenu des contrôles qui
étaient fait sur ce sujet ce n'est pas
le seul moyen d'envoyer de facturer des
prestations immatérielles ailleurs c'est
juste une petite chose mais cette petite
chose fait que de réelles entreprises de
réelles producteurs de réels
exportateurs préfèrent produire ailleurs
simplement parce que c'est trop
difficile d'expliquer sa politique de
prix compte tenu des exence de notre de
notre code des impôts et j'attire
l'attention là-dessus parce que
aujourd'hui je je pense qu'on est allé
trop loin et qu'on d'une certaine
manière n'aide pas nos entreprises à
créer de la valeur exporter et donc à
participer et à payer de l'impôt par
leur
réussite dans la suite du débat la
parole est à Monsieur Alain vidalis
ministre chargé des Relations avec le
Parlement
monsieur le
Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je vous prie de bien vouloir
excuser pierre moscoviss qui est
actuellement en déplacement déplacement
prévu de longue date et que il n'a pas
pu annuler compte tenu des modifications
de l'ordre du jour du Sénat intervenu
dans des circonstances que vous
connaissez pour ma part je suis heureux
d'être parmi vous ce matin pour assister
et participer à ce débat d'une grande
importance monsieur le rapporteur Éric
Boquet vous avez contribué dans un
premier rapport à initier le mouvement
de lutte acharnée contre l'évasion et la
fraude fiscale que le gouvernement met
en œuvre d'une manière déterminée depuis
quelques mois vous vous êtes interrogé
cette fois-ci de manière plus spécifique
sur le rôle des banques dans le
phénomène de lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale
international c'est évidemment un sujet
central qui peut être traité à travers
deux aspect principalement la lutte
contre
l'opacité fiscal et le secret bancaire
d'une part et la lutte contre le
blanchiment d'autre part vous avez
compris que le gouvernement a fait de la
lutte contre la fraude fiscale une
priorité de sa politique en cette
période de crise économique et sociale
où les Français sont mis à contribution
pour le redressement du pays la fraude
alliant l'injustice au sentiment
d'impunité devient purement et
simplement
insupportable c'est ce qui détermine
l'action du gouvernement dans sa lutte
contre les paradis fiscaux il s'agit de
rendre moins attractifs ces territoires
pour resserrer les taux contre les
fraudeurs il s'agit de développer les
moyens d'investigation pour identifier
ceux qui ne paient pas l'impôt du il
s'agit enfin de développer les sanctions
pour ne pas laisser impunis ce qui
mcnaissent ou détournent les règles un
mot d'introduction avant de répondre à
quelquesunes de vos questions pour
insister sur le fait qu'en matière de
lutte contre les paradis fiscaux on ne
peut pas agir seul beaucoup d'entre vous
pour ne pas dire tous l'ont dit et
constaté les évolutions
internationales sont décisives ce qui
s'est produit depuis plusieurs mois et
inédit et je crois pouvoir dire que
l'action de la France compte pour
beaucoup dans cette évolution mais pour
lutter contre l'opacité fiscale de
certains territoires rien n'est possible
sans l'établissement vous l'avez dit de
normes internationales et donc sans
l'action de l'Union européenne et du
G20 en ce qui concerne en premier lieu
la lutte contre l'opacité fiscale et le
secret bancaire je voudrais rappeler les
quelques évolutions décisives qui se
sont déroulées ces derniers mois sur le
plan international en rappelant que dans
ces domaines c'est évidemment ce niveau
d'action qui est
décisif il a un jour été dit il n'y a
pas si longtemps le secret bancaire est
terminé
c'était après le G20 de Londres qui a
donné une impulsion décisive à ses
travaux sur le international mais n'a
pas éradiqué loin sans faux le secret
bancaire alors je comprends que l'on
soit un peu méfiant désormais lorsque
l'on entend que le monde a basculé c'est
la raison pour laquelle le gouvernement
vous dit aujourd'hui c'est que le secret
bancaire
vacille comme il n'a jamais
vacillé mais je pense qu'il faut avoir
en tête aujourd'hui et c'est un un fait
absolu ent inédit qu'un véritable
consensus a émergé pour prendre des
mesures efficaces afin que chacun pe sa
juste part d'impôt plus précisément une
idée s'est affirmée qui est celle de la
transparence fiscale certains raillent
le fait que sans les États-Unis qui ont
mis en place cette législation d FAA
rien ne se serait produit dit exact que
cette législation de 2010 qui institue
une obligation pour les établissements
financiers étrangers de fournir aux ait
aux autorités fiscales américaines des
informations détaillées sur les comptes
bancaires détenus par les contribuables
américains a marqué un tournom mais
faut-il s'en plaindre dès lors que c'est
cette législation qui nous permet
aujourd'hui de demander à nos
partenaires européens et bientôt du G20
une formation équivalente à celle que
fourniront les États-Unis je ne le pense
pas le fait qu'un État a su imposer à
ses partenaires les plus récalcitrant le
principe de l'échange automatique
d'information a permis à ses partenaires
européens la France en premier lieu de
porter le sujet plus haut que jamais
dans les instances internationales et
d'en faire désormais le standard par
ailleurs si les évolutions internation
sont décisives cela ne signifie pas pour
autant que nous restions inactifs sur le
plan interne ou bilatéral j'en veux pour
preuve la signature de la convention
succession avec la Suisse entre Pierre
Moscovici et son homologue au mois de
juillet dernier qui contient des
dispositions importantes en matière
d'échange de renseignement ou encore le
projet de loi de lutte contre la fraude
qui contient par exemple cet amendement
prévoyant d'inscrire sur notre liste
interne des paradis fiscaux tous les
États qui auront refusé de s'engager
dans le domaine de l'échange automatique
d'information à ceux qui auraient voulu
croire ou auraient commenté que tout
serait détruit notamment ceux dont je
viens de parler par la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel je veux rappeler
que il a validé la quasittalité des
mesures et que ce sont des mesures très
importantes vous avez évoqué dans ce
débat toute une série de de questions
qui viennent naturellement lorsqu'on
aborde ces ces problèmes essentiel je
voudrais essayer de répondre
à
quelques-unes certaines sont rédbitoires
dans ce type de débat et notamment cell
évoqué par plus plusieurs d'entre vous
sur le verrou de
Bery vous le savez il s'agit d'abord de
bien préciser ce dont on parle car le
verrou en question il ne concerne pas
que il ne concerne que le délit de
fraude fiscale mais comme vous le dites
d'ailleurs dans votre rapport pas
l'ensemble des infractions fiscales et
notamment vous le citez vous-même dans
la commission d'enquête le carousel de
TVA j'ajoute que si on veut être
objectif et regarder
l'évolution du droit et de la pratique
administrative l'émergence ces dernières
années dans le bilan des poursuites de
l'infraction de blanchiment de fraude
fiscale et qui permet d'éviter du point
de vue de la procédure ce que vous
évoquez paraît aboutir à un juste
équilibre en ce qui concerne l'action de
l'administration et l'action de la
justice vous avez d'ailleurs monsieur le
rapporteur dans la logique de cette
question interroger le gouvernement sur
l'action de Tracfin et notamment sur les
questions d'échange d'information en ce
qui concerne le contrôle fiscal Tracfin
a adressé à l'administration fiscale
près de 400 notes de renseignement entre
le 1er octobre 2009 et le 31 décembre
2012 ces renseignements ont été
exploités et à ce jour des rappels
d'impôt de près de 500 millions d'euros
ont été effectués et des plaintes pour
fraude fiscal ont été également déposé
par l'administration fiscale
l'administration fiscale transmet aussi
régulièrement dans l'autre sens des
informations à tracf
572 signalements ont été transmis en
2012 il est toujours possible
naturellement
d'améliorer les la circulation
d'information mais je souhaitais vous
rappeler très précisément ces chiffres
et qui correspondent à la préoccupation
légitime que vous avez
exprimé en ce qui concerne la question
de l'abus de droit qui a été évoqué par
le Président vous évoquez l'importance
de cette procédure je vous confirme
qu'elle est cruciale pour permettre à
l'administration
de procéder au redressement al je vous
rappelle à cet égard que l'Assemblée
nationale en seconde partie du PLF a
adopté des dispositions qui viennent de
la renforcer de la même façon que
l'Assemblée nationale a voté
l'obligation de déclaration préalable au
schéma d'optimisation fiscale ce qui
semble aller dans le sens de vos
préoccupation en ce qui concerne les
modalités de régularisation fiscale la
question a été posé par rapport à la
mise en application de la
circulaire dite case Ne de juin
2013 le succès de cette procédure qui
repose sur la transparence et le droit
commun contrairement à toutes les
procédures antérieures est désormais
incontesté près de 9000 procédure cel a
été dit par certains d'entre vous ont
été engagé à ce jour or c'est
précisément la prise de conscience par
nos concitoyens que les progrès de la
lutte dans la fraude et notamment le
progrès de l'échange automatique
d'information ne laisse plus de place au
comportements et aux espérances entre
guillemets des frraudeurs ce qui est
manifestement à l'origine du succès de
la mise en œuvre de cette
circulaire monsieur le le président
monsieur le rapporteur pardon vous
avez considéré il peut être un constat
si on veut bien regarder l'histoire sur
le sujet que vous évoquez que la finance
risque d'être toujours en avance sur la
législation et c'est une façon me
semble-t-il objective forte de poser de
poser le problème mais c'est au fond la
raison pour laquelle l'arsenal de
mesures adopté dans le cadre de projet
de loi de lutte contre la fraude danst
la quasi-totalité des dispositions
viennent d'être validé par le Conseil
constitutionnel c'est la raison pour
laquelle cette disposition cette loi est
essentielle nous renforçons à travers
cette loi les moyens de l'administration
fiscale dans sa course comme vous
l'évoquez avec la finance il faut
rappeler ici sans rentrer dans le détail
mais que la police judiciaire fiscale
verra ses compétences élargies que la
fraude fiscale commise en bande
organisée sera plus lourdement
sanctionné que l'administration dispose
a de nouvelles informations issues des
réculations financierses que la
possibilité de contrôle pour
l'administration pour lutter contre la
fraude fiscale des entreprises sera
considérablement renforcé je pense que
on peut poser la question mais que c'est
pas une raison pour baisser les bras et
que dans tous les cas c'est pas la
position du gouvernement et que tant
qu'il faudra si on doit avoir des moyens
législatifs
complémentaires nous les mettrons en en
place et puis il y a cette question
majeure évoquée par la plupart d'entre
vous pour répondre à la question comment
la France agit-elle pour promouvoir
mettre en œuvre l'échange automatique
d'information je suis d'accord avec
votre constat monsieur le rapporteur
l'échange sur demande à montrer
aujourd'hui ses limites c'est
précisément d'ailleurs la raison pour
laquelle la France le gouvernement se
bat au sein des instances
internationales pour en faire un
standard
incontournable au niveau européen la
directive épargne sera discuté lors du
Conseil Ecofin de la semaine prochaine
et s'il le faut au Conseil européen de
fin de l'année par ailleurs une nouvelle
directive qui couvrira l'ensemble des
revenus avec l'échange automatique est
en cours de discussion au niveau du G0
l'échange automatique a été reconnu
comme un standard et la France a
beaucoup pesé dans cette évolution au
niveau interne vous avez souligné que le
Conseil constitutionnel a considéré que
l'introduction d'un critère d'échange
automatique dans notre liste de paradis
fiscaux et étaé
disons prématuré car
disproportionné je ne partage pas votre
pessimiste sur la suite des événements
nous poursuivons l'analyse de la
décision du gouvernement dans par
définition le la décision pardon du
Conseil constitutionnel dont le
gouvernement par définition ne peut que
prendre acte mais cela n'enlève pas la
volonté et la détermination du
gouvernement
à poursuivre ses objectifs tels qu'il
les avait inscrits initialement dans la
loi je voudrais répondre à Madame Goulet
qui a
évoqué la nécessité ou son intérêt pour
le statut des lanceurs
d'alertees comprendra que j'y suis
particulièrement attentif mais elle me
permettra aussi leses propos ne
s'adressent pas à elle mais que je
considère effectivement et le
gouvernement et nous l'avons montré dans
deux lois différentes y compris dans la
loi sur la transparence de la vie
publique que le statut de lanceur
d'alerte est une innovation et une
modernisation importante encore
faudrait-il encore
faudrait-il que dans le concert européen
lorsque la France veut promouvoir ce
concept il ne se fasse pas on ne lui
renvoie pas l'écho de nos débats dans
les hémicycles où pour certains pour
beaucoup trop et lanceurs d'aleres
deviennent des délateurs ou les lanceurs
d'alertes deviennent ce que la France a
connu de pire dans les périodes de son
histoire je sais pas vous j'ai pris la
précaution de le dire mais je veux
rappeler que même si nous sommes allé
jusqu'au bout cette évolution s quand
même heurtée à des débats et qui sont un
peu en contradiction avec ce que nous
évoquons aujourd'hui s'agissant de la
transmission de l'échange d'information
peut pas à la fois être pour l'échange
d'information automatique à tous les
niveaux et puis s'opposer simplement à
la mise en œuvre des lanceurs d'alerte
au niveau de l'initiative citoyenne je
n'insiste pas mais il y a là me
semble-t-il sur le plan conceptuel pour
le moins et probablement politique une
contradiction qui est une contradiction
majeure
je pense avoir répondu à l'essentiel des
questions qui ont été posées je m'excuse
auprès de ceux qui étaient dans
l'attente d'autres précisions je crois
que beaucoup de vos interventions se se
recoupai et été nourri par l'excellent
travail de votre de votre commission je
n'ai pas euh totalement adhéré à
l'intervention de Monsieur Duvernois ou
dans tous les cas elle m'a parfois euh
surpris naturellement il comprendra que
son sa pétition de principe selon
laquelle le matraquage fiscal peut
expliquer l'évasion fiscale supposerait
un débat euh d'une notre nature où
chaque mot devrait être repris ou dans
tous les cas réinscrit dans une histoire
y compris de ces dernières années qui
permettrai d'éclairer le débat sur la
notion de matraquage fiscal euh mais
surpl sur le plan du principe même je
pense qu'on mélange là deux concepts et
que c'est une comparaison qui est
porteuse de dangers j'ajoute je viens de
l'évoquer que effectivement à la suite
d'une affaire que vous avez évoqué
vous-même
comme Madame
Gouet le gouvernement a réagi et que les
lois sur la transparence ont été au
rendez-vous de ces cette
situation monsieur Chiron je veux
reprendre ce qui a été dit à la fin de
son intervention qui reprenait un peu
l'ensemble des votes les taux se
resserrent mais la bataille est loin
d'être gagnée c'était aussi me
semble-t-il l'esprit et la conclusion du
rapport d'information oui la bataille
n'est pas gagnée mais les taux se
resserrent et l'action du Gouvernement
sur le plan européen sur le plan
international sur le plan du droit
interne à à travers toutes les
initiatives que j'ai rappelé contribue à
resserrer les taux et dans le moment où
la question la question fiscale est au
cœur du débat mais c'est naturel car la
question fiscale n'est pas une question
technique c'est une question politique
parce qu'elle pose le problème bien sûr
de la justice fiscale mais surtout elle
porte elle pose le problème de la
question du respect du pacte républicain
et c'est en ce sens qu'elle est une
question majeure et essentielle et merci
d'y avoir contribué par vos travaux ce
matin
merci voilà pour ce débat consacré hier
aux conclusions de la commission
d'enquête sur le rôle des banques dans
l'évasion fiscale vous l'avez vu dans
l'hémicycle il y a un véritable
consensus droite gauche sur ce sujet
consensus pour mettre en place un fatka
Européen c'est-à-dire un système
d'échange automatique d'information ce
sujet est pris de plus en plus sérieux
au niveau européen également au niveau
mondial puisque l'évasion fiscale a été
un thème largement abordé lors des
derniers G20 et G8 vous pouvez bien sûr
toujours voir et revoir toutes les
séances sur notre site
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire cet après-midi
à 19h avec 24h Sénat très bonne journée
sur les chaînes
parlementaires